two I do that the last I did do that the
last episode because there's so much
James
Charles although he dropped the high
right it was a how did he start his
apology video hi this is James Charles
like we know who you are see your
face hi sisters would that be great if
he started it with that though he's like
listen I'm dedicated to the high Sisters
Let's Get Glam all right guys welcome
everybody to another edition of after
dark it's Friday and we love Fridays
don't we folks we sure do I love Fridays
especially because my beautiful wife and
co-host sits beside me here today on
Friday which I love and who looks am
dude stand up stand up sh let's see what
dude Eva commission this cool ass artist
to make her a full outfit give us a Twi
come on what up big pimps
yeah oh she's getting up on the chair no
show them the shoes do it to him do it
to him do it to
him here do
it oh my
God
yeah that was not stupid that was
awesome that was epic
icon um yeah I like to dress up to after
dark even though like you barely see
anything well that's why I'm showing you
off girl D it's like it gives me a
reason to to do something i' like to
take your ass
bowling it's like a date night it's like
a bad like but like you know you
well let me explain when you really like
a girl in like high school or something
you take them bowling okay but you said
it like
take even though it's like the worst
date ever you we can go anytime no I
don't want to actually take you bowling
I it's so loud it's so bowling is the
worst date but you always do it with the
girls you really like in high school so
remember I'm going to take your ass
bowling
girl
damn um listen today I'm not I kid you
not is an incredible show first of all
of course we're going to watch James
Charles apology video apology World Tour
but that's not even like what I'm most
excited
about I mean I talked about James
Charles in the last episode did not
expect him to come out and
admit to the crimes he's being alleged
of I it's fit yeah I saw that it's okay
I'm actively searching for younger
people to be in relationship with what
James say that
again I'm actively searching for younger
people to be in a relationship with wait
should you really be saying
that well that's kind of what I was
saying with this video I was like wow I
can't believe he said that I would date
like the absolute Young
oh well yeah that's being honest I mean
he's being honest finally I'm desperate
yeah yeah
clearly um okay so we are having today
by popular demand the sound bite bracket
World
Championship where we are going to be
doing a live we're going to show the
origin of each sound bite and have a a
live bracket that everyone vote on to
see which sound bite is the greatest
love that I am so excited and I and I uh
and it's all of our top hits and I I
don't I don't know how to pick I feel
like I need to abstain from voting to
not influence so are we like going to
explain the origin we've got the clip
yeah the origin clip and the whole
bracket wow it's going to be epic and
then after that you guys know that last
week we we put out a call to the world
to make Wendy Williams farting remixes
and boy did the world answer and
actually there's some new farts too
which I feel bad because this these
could have made good
instrumentals so but anyway there's that
and and of course the biggest surprise
of all James Charles is going to be
calling in today
really yes
come on man no way I swear to God and so
embarrassing James Charles is calling in
to comment on his apology video so
there's a lot to look forward
to let's just jump right into it what do
you
say oh and sponge oh yeah one thing real
fast we don't have a sponsor today so
let me go to Teddy fresh.com and show
you that this is your last chance ever
ever ever ever ever
everever ever to get SpongeBob X Teddy
fresh ever and unfortunately that's hot
almost everything is sold out but what
you can get is this shirt mhm this
shirt that's this
hoodie I don't know how many are left of
this but this
hoodie epic right that's all I have to
say about that oh that's hot
popups get off of popup my own
website all right
yall ready for this James Charles
holding myself accountable
yes
brother I'm trying not to talk about
drama all the time but it's
like kind of a like the two biggest
creators getting like
absolutely I mean what can you say you
it's like Dan said yesterday you can you
really call committing a crime being
cancelled I completely been thinking the
same thing I keep saying I keep seeing
people using the word cancel it's like
it's not
really if you commit a crime did we
cancel Bill
Cosby no he's in jail he's literally in
jail right now but people even if
anything he got away with it for years
so
finally with social media that's Bill
Cosby story that's how it blew up right
with um you're right with social media
so like at a some point you know I feel
like cancel culture is a catch up that
is not is not appropriate in times like
this this is not canceling James Charles
this is James Charles admitting to
felonies I'll never forget it all
started with the Hy ball right the BBY
standup yeah yeah Bill Cosby like
apparently it was like a well-known
secret that Bill Cosby was this predator
and Hannibal burus went on stage and
he's like y'all should look up Bill
Cosby just Google his name and see like
that guy is whatever whatever yeah
trying to be PG-13 here here and then
apparently people did cuz hanal was like
super popular at the time M and then
like a year later he was asked his old
ass was in jail [__] at least they
have Jello in
jail probably I that seems like jail
food to me Jello
yeah so that's good feel right at
home so this is not cancelling this is
literally someone admitting to a felony
okay
it's like stop trying to cancel James
it's like bro he said he [__] wants
he he's flirting with children I'm
actively searching for younger people to
be in a relationship with right few
comments before we get started the hair
is
outrageous what do we think about the
hair he really got glammed up for this
though you know people keep talking
about this haircut and the fact that
like the Lopez brothers and everybody
has hair I'm glad somebody's finally
saying it because that haircut [__]
suckss man and there does seem to be a
pattern well to to I mean in their
defense Dan you I mean you don't even
have
hair I mean that's not a low blow I'm
just saying
like I'm just saying like how are you
going to J what the [__] does that mean
what the hell douche
Ethan I guess what I trying to say is
like you know nah there's no way to
defend my I apologize again there was a
joke
there you know it's like someone who
can't drive motorcross being like Oh
those guys don't know what they're doing
it's nothing you're saying Dan doesn't
Glam up he's like he's like in the he's
like in the uh he's in the pit he's in
the audience watching the Dodgers play
and he's giving [__] to the pitcher it's
like I'd like to see you throw
but how are you any different than then
that's what you do it was a bad analogy
I apologize bad joke I apologize I think
you look great dude people have been
sing for you like by the way someone did
okay first of all I see a lot of people
saying Dan is the new heart yeah like
what what the [__] is that you see you
see that don't act like you don't see it
okay Dan just to even out because I was
such an [__] a moment ago and I
apologize to and I feel
bad I'm going to pull up
um someone did like a oh here it is H3
podcast the movie okay you want to see
how here you want to see what okay look
people cast us in a movie okay on the
subu all right Dan so now all the sudden
just take okay here's me I'm Aziz andari
yeah okay oh my God you guys do look
similar yeah that's crazy I've never
made that connection okay so there's me
okay and then before you feel too before
everyone feels too bad for for Dan look
who's this is Elo from from The
Shining this is Dan oh really
Timberland Timberlake Timberland that's
justtin I thought they were going to do
Bruce Willis that's Dan okay so before
anyone starts feeling bad that I Bruce
Willis really Justin get Dan get to be
Justin timberl that's fair I'm confused
that's a picture of Justin Timberlake
yeah yeah why are you confused that's
clearly him yeah here I'll zoom in all
the way I guess I maybe just never seen
him with a beard before
maybe Al so there you go I'm aiz and
you're Justin Timberland what who's that
I think Ian gets that all the time Scott
I
guess not really but there's like maybe
a vibe that there's a Vibe there's some
kind of he's been getting that for years
me Daddy Ian you don't look like I don't
see it at all really no there's
something to it
survive we love it though I think I'm
closer to
this wait who that you look closer to
Robin Williams from
jii St saying that why were you so once
the air gets longer The Jungle Room
takes over this is going to be me right
right what year is it is that from
that's from like Princess Bride or
something Zach gets this this is a
compliment to Z that's yeah quite
accurate too I love that
who is
that you ask who is this it's Jack Black
it's Jack Black oh from Orange County
okay I just didn't recognize
him Jack
Black yeah he does look he does look
really young there and then um AB of
course which everyone always says yeah
oh Remy ory know how to say his name
ryy Ramy that's that's a star studded uh
that's a star studded movie for me but I
don't mind shy do balls an icon okay I
think you're totally an icon I like it
though she's got I see the zance but I
think
zance the resemblance resemblance are
you like
shortened I got the resemblance I see
the resemblance yeah the resemblance
sorry I'm not perfect we're resembling
get your word straight Jack oh shut up
Joe Biden you're the one that [__]
can never say you're the Gaff Master Joe
Biden come on man like you have a
country to run oh no I probably best I
don't anyway so so before you feel too
bad for Dan he's the most handsome man
in the [__] room apparently right
[__] me in the ass right sorry I good
man I can't believe how much you look
like aits like you've never seen that
people yeah people I've never I guess
they kind of stopped but there was a
time when it was like
like Anyway this is the what they call
the Predator poof oh and actually there
was one I saw his brother who's also
accused of being or well I don't even
know if it's an it's not even alleged at
this point you probably know AB it's
crazy both the Lopez brothers are like
straight up Predators both of them both
the twins one of them was even recorded
by the mom of like a 14-year-old was it
AB do you know
uh I'll I'll fact check yeah she was
really young one of them the mom called
him and was like yo you need to meet me
today W cuz I know what you did what was
on the agenda oh my God maybe we should
pull that up get a little background on
the Predator proof can someone pull that
up for me and this guy's still dancing
on Tik Tok he's still like oh yeah and
all the I'm Chris Hansen with dine
NBC is chrison on Tik Tok so this is the
haircut you should not get so so like I
said previous on the previous
episode if a celebrity adds you on
Snapchat you're going to be assaulted if
a celebrity with a haircut like
this approaches you if anyone with this
haircut approaches you in any way
disappear move be
scarce this is the Predator
poof
you what is wrong with that woman when
she make she makes sounds like I never
heard it's kind of have we watched that
one yet on the show do move but there's
okay let's not get ahead of ourselves
but I do want to listen to that phone
call to give some context if anyone's
found it I don't think it was a phone
call it was a video I remember when we
were talking about it seeing a video
that she was like secretly recording
when he was in the room video audio
whatever you got oh here's his BR his
brother didn't really have the
poof
I'm just waiting oh we got it nice we
got
it nice nice nice this is it thank you
um can you hack into my main frame Dam
and and screwed up speed up my
scroll my drag speed
sure I'll do it once there's like but
you want be able to do anything yeah I
know but it's just too SL kill the
[Music]
music
we just got a new laptop if you guys
were wondering we just got a new
laptop our last one was a piece of crap
dog [__] and so there's just some some
little gaffs and goof here but anyway
this is his homie and you are home Crank
That
23 yeah you know what can happen to you
I
do I do you can end up in
jail I do realize that
that's the we need to talk in person
yeah and I'm bringing my daughter with
me and my sister and we need to figure
this out this mom is just Cloud chasing
I'm sorry she just Cloud chasing
obviously just Cloud chasing um whenever
did you bring
con TR stop trying to cancel the Lopez
brothers you these people are just Cloud
chasing yours
um where is the good
place
um I I I mean yeah I don't know why he's
not in
jail you know maybe he paid him off
maybe but she still put the video out
which is I guess she's like I'm going to
[__] you and pay me probably should have
put him in the police though if you
really cared so these are make it feel
really good for you H so these twin
brothers are still crushing it on
um Tik Tok and these are friends of
James Charles so I mean as far as I'm
aware this is like a whole ring of
predators like they all associate
together they share notes they all have
the same haircut and they're all super
popular still I'm actively searching for
younger people to be in a relationship
with I mean James said it himself right
there I don't know what to say I just
it's like when the me too wave happened
and it was just like oh my God all these
people are creeps it's yeah and I kind
of feel like it's happening with all
these influencers now it's crazy it's me
too tube me too tube all right with all
that being said let's get into this
sister snatch 14 minutes of self-pity
let's get Glam let's get
Glam now by the way this is the quietest
apology this takes the medal for the
quietest apology in YouTube history it's
so quiet that I mean we had to boost it
likes hello everyone James Char hello
everyone um is it loud and today I'm
going to be making a very important
video about a very important topic as
many of you guys know about 2 years ago
now I was involved with a very public
online scandal in which some fellow
YouTubers made some very serious
accusations against me and within the
past couple of weeks similar accusations
are being made again so as you know
sisters I was some serious accusations
were made against me and in the past two
weeks we found out they were all
true so as you know 3 years ago I've
already been through this and um here we
are again nothing's changed I've clearly
not learned my lesson well what he's
trying to do is conflate the tati thing
which he was like everyone's like James
won epic Victory he took her out to
this different [__] Bro different
[__] and I think it's very important
that I get on camera and talk to you
guys honestly about what is going oh
also I want to sorry keep pausing but
don't you think it's ironic as a lock
and key like why would you wear of all
the things on your earrings when you're
about to go to jail a lock and
key oh no you know what I mean oh no
like damn bro desperation desperation
anything else than that you know what's
good about his haircut though you could
probably hide like a shiv in there if he
was in
jail if he needed to protect himself see
the what all the memes of like it has
like a bird's nest in there and [__]
yeah bird's
nest you could definitely hide some
Contraband into prison with that so
that's really good news for him on uh
when this first happened two years ago I
uploaded a video to my channel called No
More Lies and that video was a very
planned video it focused on receipts and
screenshots and defending myself in the
situation but I want you guys to know
that this video that I'm going to be
making today is going going to be
nothing like no more lies uh this is not
exactly planned I don't have a script I
will let you guys know that I do have
just some notes in front of me of points
that I want to make because this is a
very very serious topic uh but today's
video is going to be from the heart and
I'm going to focus on what happened uh
the conclusions that I've come to and
most importantly holding myself
accountable for my out actions do you
know how to hold yourself accountable
turn yourself
in I'll just be your secret
lover right yeah I mean accountability
means like I'm here to turn myself in
not try to salvate your career on
YouTube I mean it's a little too early
let's just keep watching I have stuff to
say
but yeah you're right control your
pausing
Ethan to say y y no no no no no no no no
skipping we're not here to skip sorry um
I owe a massive apology to anybody that
I've hurt or anybody that I made
uncomfortable with my actions and I also
want to say I'm sorry to my friends
family and fans that have to watch
another one of these videos because you
shouldn't have to and this is really
really embarrassing uh when this all
started online a few weeks ago it
sparked a large conversation and many
people have shared their thoughts and
opinions and I want to take some time to
address literally everything in today's
video um but before doing that I want to
make it really really clear that I fully
understand my actions and how they are
wrong uh there's no excuse for them and
I don't plan on making any in this video
either and I hope that you will choose
to watch it all the way through there
you go um I also just want to make a
quick note as well that I'm filming this
on the night of March 31st it is
currently 12:54 in the morning um I'm
alone here in the stud again so this was
an interesting point that a lot of
people pointed out that David made the
same I was about to say it's the David
formula
so I I have Studio that I'm alone it's
late at night and I'm all by
myself does anyone else have a theory or
shall I put mine forward I have um
something I'd love to hear it I feel
like he's making this into a dating
profile and I'm going to get more into
it as he keeps talking but he's like I'm
going to talk so soft and I'm here alone
and I I just wish I had a friend you
know oh yeah wait till you watch the
rest exactly so it's like so not the
tone he really is playing his own victim
up yeah I'm alone but so what I think it
is the vibe that I get when like David
and James Charles say it is they're
they're trying to be so to Humble
themselves cuz they're like I'm so
important I there's I'm always
surrounded by people yeah I am never
alone because there's just so much going
on in my life but in this moment I
before yourself have kneeled and to
atone for my sins I have sent everybody
away from me be gone
peasants empty the court and also if
there's a sound issue it's because
there's no sound guy here
right that's good the video is quiet
that actually would explain the the
level
actually uh so it's like you know and if
my poof is not perfect there's no hair
person here it is perfect he he he
brought in a Glam Squad he's like okay
just the Glam Squad be
gone this is personal so that's what I I
think it's like this power thing of like
they even if I don't even think it's
conscious but they have this perception
of themselves of such important big
pieces of brand there's always just
surrounded and so much going on so to
them it's this humbling moment to be
alone by themselves do you think what do
you think of my um I agree with you um
thank you you do always hear from these
people that kind of like me and my team
you know my team
um but in this moment there is no team
I've emptied the court and it's just
I all my advisers and kings and jesters
and my Glam Squad and my airing men and
and it's 1 a.m I really just don't sleep
it's 1:00 a.m. I've had such a long day
so if anyone still wants to come hang
out with me I I'm sure it's like you
just can't turn it off this is totally a
dating profile as you keep watching is
like look I just I'm just looking for
someone who's like around my age can
make me laugh and like hey hit me up
yeah we have contradictory evidence to
that
claim actually go ahead and play it Zach
you know what I'm talking about I'm
actively searching for people he said on
impulsive that he um he can't help it
he's just here I'll pull it up he can't
I'm not physically attracted to older
guys yeah that one is not actually taken
out of
context as you fine well well fine why
don't you come visit like well I can't
afford a plane ticket it's like okay
well I can so like get on the plane and
like well I just don't really feel
comfortable with
that good one to watch there's a few
things to
watch did could you highlight it for me
please let's get
Glam that is not it and I'm like well we
can't be together because you can't
afford a plane ticket you're probably
still in either high school or college
like senior in high school or in college
so either you accept why why are they in
high school I love this clip and by the
way Logan Paul peace and love like I
love that he didn't say anything yeah
did you just say you're trying to date
people in high school right sorry back
up what realiz that like this is what
I'm bringing to the relationship why
don't you come visit like well I can't
afford a plane ticket it's like okay
well I can so like get on the plane and
like well I just don't really feel
comfortable with that but like I love
you and I really want to be together and
I'm like well we can't be together
because you can't afford a plane ticket
you're probably still in either high
school or college like senior in high
school anyway this one's about he says
he doesn't understand the power Dynamic
later in the video I'm getting ahead of
myself did you find a clip of him saying
he's only attracted to younger guys
where is that one that he's looking to
date younger Z just played it didn't he
yeah but there's a clip of it on the
from the same podcast I believe it's the
only clip we have from uh impulsive in
the do we don't got
it I could look for it
though and oh my God it's so quiet this
when I upload this tomorrow it is going
to be April Fool's Day which is awful
timing because this video and this topic
is not a joke in any way shape or form
uh and I it is awful do you think you
should have waited a day cuz when I saw
you upload this on April fools like what
an
idiot I think he didn't need to wait to
shoot this until 1:00
a.m. not that I know what goes on in his
day but I feel like it's pretty
important he could have shot it earlier
at least he acknowledged that it was
April Fool's you know but damn dog
there's 365 days in the year and you all
[__] chose April fools to upload this
anybody to think that it is but I also
don't want to wait any longer to speak
about this I want you guys to know that
this is very very important to me and
I'm taking this very very seriously uh
the last thing that I want to say before
I just get into it is that I think it's
important that I provide a trigger
warning for this video uh there's going
to be topics and things talked about
that are very very sensitive uh to some
people and I don't want anybody to have
to listen to those if they don't want to
so I'm just letting you know right now
um but with all that said I think it's
time that we talk in case anybody isn't
aware of what's going on within the past
couple of weeks two different people
both under the age of 18 have recently
come forward saying that they had
inappropriate messages to me on social
media uh one of them being from last
year and one of them being from more
recent uh in both of these cases I added
these people on Snapchat asked how old
they were were right away was told that
they were 18 believe them engage in a
flirty conversation and then later on
found out that they were actually
16 done close it up lock the video up
end the video what else do we need to
hear well also I I like how he says
flirty I mean I've seen some of these
DMS bro this Beyond flirty yeah like
flirty is a very [__] nice euphemism
to use for the kind of a conversation
you had I seen those photos bro that you
that you exchanged it I was like who oh
dude he's got a very pushy tone like oh
so pushy if you read the DMS and all the
leaks he's super pushy and gross and
he's always pressuring people to like
outside the comfort zone like just do it
like why won't you just do it come on
LOL just just show me your armpit just
show me your armpit a but it's like kids
that look up to him and they don't know
anything you know and it's like it
really makes me feel bad but um it's
like hey so why is the video any longer
than this just like I don't need to hear
anything else you've already been in
this drama exactly this Story 3 years
ago and so you didn't learn anything you
find people you think are attractive on
social media then you go follow them on
Snapchat o big flag it's like that's
what we called in the last episode it's
basically where it's that app where
celeberties go to commit crimes and then
the first thing he's asking them is
what's their age so he knows he knows
what he's doing he knows they're most
likely on the verge of not being age
appropriate yes so considering you've
already been through this you would
think it would do a little more than
just believe what they say you know how
when you it's gross yes it is James you
know how when you go like people don't
card me anymore when I go to buy alcohol
but when I was close to 21 I get carded
all the time mhm it's like kind of like
that like right like when you are having
to ask someone's
age then you shouldn't be exchanging
dudes with them online and also later in
the video in this video he says I should
have done better research if if you look
at their social media profile you can
tell their age yes it's like but you
said you found them on on social media
and then went and followed them on
Snapchat so right there you're saying
you did know their age he knew it's bro
and you know what's crazy is that people
are eating this up look at the like this
like ratio well because they just don't
know better I don't I don't blame them
they're literally like 12-year-old girls
it's always like that it's just people
don't want to believe that someone would
do something like that it's easier to
take the route of believing him because
they don't want to think that but he but
he's saying it all you know what I mean
that's what's crazy he is saying it all
now now comes all the spin where he's
like yes I did flirt with 16year olds
but here's
why your
honor oh by the way we found the clip
thank you guys just so you know he
says here starting it's really looking
period like I'm actively searching for
younger people to be in a relationship
with and I just want to say firsthand
that that is absolutely not the case My
Hope has always been to be in a
relationship with somebody around my age
or older that I can relate to it and
that could make me laugh and
unfortunately I've not been able to find
that person yet I'm not physically
attracted to older guys which sucks like
I would date like the absolute youngest
like 18 19 that looks a little bit older
um by the way can you appreciate that it
like it's a clip of us
reacting to James the circulating of us
now reacting to it apparently this clip
is buried somewhere it's on his podcast
but like yeah he goes I mean again he
says I am not
I I want the youngest possible legal
person anyway let's keep watching so now
now now we get into the Spin Zone
finding out I was immediately
embarrassed and blocked both people
later on when I saw making videos about
I block like like I engaged in this uh
because in his written apology he said I
thought I had found someone
special he's like oh [__] you a block
you know what I mean it's like the whole
attitude is just so weird
the the dude has got problems man this
dude listen with peace and love what if
they feel used and feel like they have
something to get off their chest blocked
you do
yeah imposter I mean this guy is clearly
a threat he cannot be allowed to
continue this he already got a second
chance this already
happened and he [__] it up like you
just don't get to do that you can
apologize for committing a crime like
you know what I mean like okay you're
you're holding yourself accountable
you're apologizing but you committed a
crime and holding yourself accountable
means going to [__] prison bro
honestly getting off YouTube I don't
know deleting your social media how
about that delete get off social media
nah he'll have a burner where he picks
up youngans
saplings there's not much to do as far
as we are concerned except just call it
out but I don't know it's a shame but
these people can continue on and have a
career like you know Bill Cosby for 40
years that's why I think it that's what
I don't want to see happen especially
James Charles is the the most um heinous
example I've seen of this in my whole
time on YouTube and the most blaton is
that if I sit back without doing
everything in my power to stop this if
our us in our community don't hold this
blatant
Predator accountable or at least call it
out and say it as loud as we can and as
frequently as can then we are complicit
there's going to be more victims and
like you're going to have another in
example people go how did Harvey
Weinstein and Bill Cosby get away with
it for so long everybody knew and they
kept doing it for years and there was
more victims and more victims and more
victims that's what's going to happen
with James that's what's going to happen
with James he's going to keep doing it
and keep doing it and have more and more
victims he already did he was already
called out and here we are again yeah
how many people get a second chance at
their job like especially on something
that
heavy you know he came back even
stronger from the first I just feel like
you're already he's already so lucky in
his position of his career and
everything going on like you don't get
to be so privileged and get a second
chance and still mess it up and get a
third chance and a fourth chance
but he is alone he cleared out the court
mhm doesn't that mean anything searching
for younger people to be in a
relationship
with going viral my immediate reaction
completely honestly was to be really
really upset I wanted to get on camera
and film another No More Lies video
where I gather all my receipts and all
my
screen yeah bro see what again he's like
listen I've evolved instead of attacking
the 16-year-olds listen I was going to
be upset you guys are the nice Jam I was
about to dunk on these 16-year-olds for
lying to me about their
age by the way that does not hold up in
court your
honor this child lied to me about their
age convict him interesting yes the
child you go to jail
child how dare you lie to your age also
in this is the you know lying about your
age age has been his reason for all of
these right from the beginning of time
has there been even once that he's shown
any proof of that of them lying about I
think at the T tati case he came back
and he showed receipts and that's why
everyone was like oh you know even we
were like okay James you know he's a
he's a young guy and let's give him a
chance maybe it was a mistake and he'll
learn from
it they do lie about their age I think
but the point is that or maybe they
don't I don't know but the point the
point regardless of lying or not is I
know that that wouldn't exonerate him in
a court at all but in the court of
public opinion that would definitely get
him sympathy points so you'd think if he
had evidence of that he would he'd share
it well he did it in the first drama I
think he understands he can continue to
do that yeah it's already like it's
becoming a joke well he he admit because
it's so obvious that if you literally
just click over to their public profile
it says like this one kid who the one
his age was all over he all these Tik
toks it said he was 15 so it's like do
like any due diligence at all it doesn't
make any sense like okay he lied to
about his age but
like B basically this is the the
timeline of events he goes hi you're
cute I want to send you dick pics okay
how old are you I'm 18 straight to
straight to Snapchat straight to dick
like he didn't click his Tik Tok check
him out like how did you discover this
guy I mean the literally doesn't make
sense you knew doesn't make sense you
knew I like to make love
oh Chris apparently he's a virgin that's
what he pulled last time to get sympathy
oh he was like this time he pulls
another spicy Ace out of the hole last
time he was a virgin this time it's that
he's lonely or desperate yeah we'll see
side of the story and then just move on
wait it's looking back that was so oh
wait the laptop was supposed to have
yeah
that point we bought a whole damn lapop
and it still happens great well so what
do I do um you wait for them to fix as
I it's not I I could still hear it
correctly on these topics and
self-reflected I realized I'm going pee
dude I've been doing this new diet where
if they drink a ton of water I have to
pee oh Jesus but Dan has to fix this
[__] anyway El look go
[Music]
ahead um let me look at the
chat keep keep fighting the good fight
hate Predators more than any anything
thank you um hopefully this doesn't
become the main focus of our show it
does feel like a lot lately but
um yeah his hair looks like a nest
ironic since he goes after kids who
haven't left the nest
yet good one good
one
um I guess I can't go back on donations
more than those two uh I've got it let's
see what else we got here somebody
donated $80 but it's a question for
Ethan who is not here what's the
question what server did he play on in
EverQuest no I don't know
that Ethan what server did you play on
on in
EverQuest what what server did you play
EverQuest what was your server I think
it was called um [__] that's you're
hitting me with some real [__] somebody
$80 they want to know what server you
played on a PVP server I think it was
called
um I played on bertox list no that
wasn't it that wasn't it how could I
forget God it was a PVP server called
uh wait PPP PVP server oh R Zac oh yeah
it was one of those yeah baby yeah it
was R Zack or there was two of them
there was like yeah there was a couple I
think it was RAC uhhuh well there you go
uh uh maybe my name was bam Nation but I
was like 12 years old when I was playing
bam Nation yeah I was an ogre Warrior
named bam Nation bam like from Jackass
no I just thought it was like bam it was
just a funny name I thought of bam
Nation you've always been about the
nation man right yeah right bam Nation
it was it was that's funny all right
let's get back to the show huh nobody
we'll play it make sure all right it
should be
fixed okay thank you for all the love in
the chat it's really there's love in the
chat a lot yeah a lot oh my goodness
it's really
nice seats and the screenshots oh this
was a moment oh havely talked about
moment the uh the hand
gestures here let's go back to uh did
more research on these topics and
self-reflected I realized that the
receipts and the screenshots and this
who does that little sister salsa yeah a
sister moment he couldn't help it dude
even in the apology you had to bring
that sister flare out
space and the specific details of the
interaction really don't matter because
I [__] up and I needed to take bro
those 16-year-olds are so [__] lucky
he didn't dunk on
them oh he didn't go like hard oh he was
about to go hard these six-year-olds but
wasn't he he kept being like involved on
Twitter with like like liking tweets
that talk badly about the victims and
things like that you know what Trisha is
always on Trisha always has the best
opinion about everything she had a great
um she had a great you know I love
Trisha she had a great take on this um
wow thank you you're welcome thank you
house just for today last day here how
did she make a two minute oh Jesus
Christ everything's so loud compared to
is okay let's get Trisha's take since
she's not here let's see what she thinks
um but yeah I saw James's
video it's it's just it's the same thing
he said after the TTI video that he was
going to do better and not be the p word
it's extremely upsetting and it's
disheartening that all his young fans
are like still buying into this with the
thumbs up ratio just keep in mind if
someone is liking tweets trying to like
take down like the victims like a week
they didn't change week like he keeps
saying I'm going to show you I'm going
to show you it's like but but you were
still trying to defend yourself by
discrediting miners like like these are
children and he kept blaming them and it
sounds good the fluff piece is good and
obviously people are buying it cuz the
thumbs up but like why are you laughing
Dan why is she recording next to a
fountain what she's always got bro I
know she's always got to swag out it's
raw
yeah
all this before you don't you don't
change it's good he's acknowledging it
and apologizing yet again but we've seen
this before this is like Groundhog Day
and this is about James so it'll
probably get taken down I don't know
okay
I'm she said it's about James so it'll
probably get taken down she's right
anyway that's I was just wanted to show
because uh that's exactly what you said
and she Trisha had a good take I thought
there yeah just a week ago he was liking
tweets of people saying that blaming the
victims and [__] I was like
okay then all of a sudden Kylie Jenner
follows you on Instagram then [__] gets
real yeah apparently all the Kardashians
unfollowed him I kept seeing
contradictory stuff about that though
people saying they they didn't follow in
the first place they were totally they
did follow I know that they were
collaborate I don't know I just when I
saw that I saw a lot of push back on
that so just put that out there I did
notice however the Chipotle video is
still on his channel
oh I just want to say that chipotle is a
stead worthy stalwart Ally you know what
predators everywhere you know what
really may have been the trigger was uh
there's the Chipotle video yep right
here Chipotle tonight I'm going to get
that spring chicken burrito
he he
um he had a a plug on that makeup
company uh taken down they had restocked
his stuff how was it called morph I say
morph and everybody was goofing on me oh
it's morphe right morphe that doesn't
sound right it should be morph I don't
like morphe I mean I didn't did you know
it was morphe I don't know that I don't
know anything about it every making
everybody's making like old old old
Ethan jokes anyway sorry Dan go ahead
XXX tasson all right well that that
company morphe they put out a promo for
his makeup palette or whatever and it
got inundated with you know negative
comments or whatever and then they took
it down and wasn't that that was like
earlier in the day of this video I
wonder if you got a call from them like
this is a problem God that's exactly
what happened yeahh taking
accountability cuz I mean I imag
obviously he gets huge numbers on
YouTube but the majority of the money he
makes I'm sure is from selling makeup So
Def
definitely yeah really
sad that's basically the vibe of this uh
of this apology
dude that's a really good uh Theory
Dan yeah I mean the balls on those
[__] I mean he must be making them
so much money to for them to have the
balls to post that in the midst of this
controversy yeah hey guys we've got new
skin tones we've got child skin tones
that are perfect if you want to make
yourself look younger or older if you're
trying to get in the DMS of James
someone like James Charles you want to
make yourself look
older I'm
desperate
all right let's keep AB said AB is
giving us a fact check here he said um
Kylie Jenner quietly unfollowed almost
all her friends on Instagram back in oh
January yeah see this is what I mean is
like how she do that people well
regardless it you know people check saw
that he wasn't being followed but I
don't think people did the same thing to
James they said like oh or sorry uh
Shane when Shane got canceled they're
like oh all the stuff's on sale on
morphe
mhm and it was already it had already
been on sale you know good for the story
though
spicy doesn't matter if it's true yeah
good for the story yeah it's good for
the story don't don't ever let the facts
get in the way of a good story true as a
saying I once heard I don't know who
said it accountability for my actions
and most importantly apologize to the
people that were affected by them these
conversations should have never happened
Point Blank period there's no excuse for
it there's no if ANS are buts and I take
full responsibility for that I trusted
the information that was given to me
rather than the information I could have
and should have gotten myself in both of
these situations doing research into
these people's public social media
profiles would have revealed their true
ages and therefore me like two yeah
which is how you found them right you
found them on social media yes so
conversations would have never happened
in more than just two oh yeah there's
like six I think there was two recently
but I think now there's been like five
people who have credibly underage
accused him of flirting in the past six
months an eight total or something it's
it's insane it's astronomical it's it's
it's a it's a it's a pandemic of sorts
so
embarrassing we've got the James Charles
pandemic there was at least two more
since our last episode yeah yeah since
Tuesday since Yer since we posted our
episode I had to put a comment saying
there's a new accuser with screenshots
who's
16 but yeah there's two dude there's
count it's obviously there's countless
there's countless this is this they lied
to you there's armies there's armies of
children God there's literal [__]
clons of children lining
up uh it's gross there's literally an
entire Kindergarten of children stop it
lining up to accuse James
Charles this is a little spooked
M can't get over that what is the
context of that do you know Zach what is
what was spook Muk
Tim I think he was just trying to do a
little play on words I think it was from
my um Halloween video very spooky Muki
yeah so play so extremely and it uh
works
well very playful
very playful we love that I didn't do
the research and that is what is so
embarrassing um as an adult it is my job
and my responsibility to verify who I'm
talking to and therefore there is no one
to blame for this other than myself up
um to like a a jail sale closing sound
bite just to hit him with every time he
basically says something we're admitting
to a crime you got it thank you
through this situation I want to say I'm
sorry I'm sorry that I added you I'm
sorry that I flirted with you and I'm
really sorry if I ever made you
uncomfortable and I'm really sorry that
I told you to put the phone on the
ground in the shower and flex and show
your armpit muscles to me and when you
said no that it made you uncomfortable I
pressed you and pressed you and said
come on I could probably finish off
without even taking my D out he
literally said
that oh I've said too much probably are
you out your
mind I said too much I read those DMS
bro I wish I could unread
them said too much
[__] and for those Reasons I'm out sorry
Martin completely unacceptable I was
being Reckless and after looking back
and finally realizing that this was my
own fault I started doing a lot of
thinking and reflecting to really try
and figure out why I was actually
allowing myself to be so reckless in the
first place go to the therapist other
areas of my life my friends by the way
since when since when has you been
reflecting cuz like just like a day yeah
it's been a few days it's been a lot of
time in the past few days reflecting
wait for this this is the big one guys
the last time he's virgin this time
guess what is the excuse that's going to
win us all over here we go here we
go business I like to think of myself as
pretty put together and on top of things
and I couldn't understand why
relationships were the one outlier why
were they not working why was this area
of me so different and I finally finally
came it's sucks and it is ridiculously
embarrassing to admit this but I think I
have to and that is that I'm desperate I
thought he was going to say I have a
problem exactly I have a problem I'm
attracted to children or very young boys
under the so again this is such a
[__] like he this is such he's
admitted so many times that he's
desperate this is not a revelation right
he's always always all the time talking
about how he can't but saying that
you're desperate it's almost like you're
trying to make it cute you know it's
almost like you know I'm just lonely and
desperate I mean look if you asked a lot
of guys on Catch a Predator who are
caught they probably say the same
thing probably a lot of them to Catch a
Predator be like I'm just desperate man
and she was giving me attention that
doesn't really hold water with James
cuzz he could he had he had no problem
getting anyone anyone he's a gay he's a
Top
gay top yeah what is that he's just he's
like one of the biggest this guy could
get James Charles get tail he's he's one
of the top
gays in the leaderboard of you know
whatever he's like a hot little
twink I'm sure there's a lot of people
in the market for that okay you're
saying he's very popular he's a catch
okay the guy's a catch right so so this
whole desperate thing is is is just it's
so dishonest that's the problem is that
you're desperate that you're continually
going after young boys like this and
using social media as dating apps that's
not desperate that's you having a
problem that you need to [__] like go
away go away from the internet
permanently and
resolve I feel like he's lost his
internet
privileges that's how I feel yeah I
don't think you get to like that's what
I was trying to say how many people get
to mess up their job and then get a
second chance and then mess up again and
keep their job bro it's way worse than
that I mean he's committing crime you
know what I mean but
yeah James is
desperate and he's behind bars I do
understand that with these videos coming
to light it's really starting to not
even starting it's really looking period
like I'm actively searching for younger
people to be in a relationship with and
I just want to say firsthand that that
is absolutely not the case
my one
sec one
moment okay remember what he said stting
I'll skip to the end this is me and
Trisha I love this
I'm not physically attracted to older
guys which sucks like I would date like
the absolute youngest like 189 that
looks a little bit old um okay go back
to James's video back it up a little
bit he's
lying he's [__] lying I'm actively
searching for younger people to be in a
relationship with and I just want to say
firsthand that's absolutely not the case
what the [__] was that that that was a
disaster of somebody that's from his
detector video oh
Jesus play that
again that's
funny oh my
God okay doesn't work well but yeah
that's what start the concept is fine
the concept's good I gave it a shot
thank you we love it you bat you bat
almost a thousand
so thank you to be relationship with
somebody around my age
older that I can relate to and that can
make me laugh and unfortunately I've not
been able to find like yeah what is this
your Tinder profile I know what why are
you descri like I don't need what else
you I want someone who has uh blonde
hair and I like someone with a petite
figure with a little bit of hair but not
too much oh AET flight he it's like okay
dude you could send your applications to
James Charles uh don't worry I'll just
find you yeah I'll find you don't look
for me I'll look for
you I I was talking about this on the
last app but can you imagine what his
Instagram explor PL page is
like oh no oh no dude his Instagram
Explorer p is like Chris Hansen's
[__] wet
dream Chris no Chris Chris Hansen's
ready to make his phone have a seat over
here oh his phone got it got that make
it feel really good for you H but you
know I'm I'm actually not kidding the
FBI should confiscate his phone and
computer like at this point mhm like I
mean
really but the idea of actually being in
a relationship became so important to me
I don't know man grle we got a wack book
hoping that thank you
[Music]
Zach um we got a wack book hoping it
would
I've replaced it's actually worse now
I've replaced every component of this
whole chain at this point the cable the
computer the converter everything but
this computer which we are getting a new
computer today actually it's finally
coming one thank you Dan so uh so I'm on
this diet I started a I got a dieti I
got a food
coach okay I'm doing just everybody say
finally doing it everyone was like Ethan
just do just stop do it the right
so I got a food coach yeah [__] it's
one of my favorite
nights I deserve a I deserve a food
coach yeah I deserve Fried Chickens
[__]
Wednesday I
um so I'm doing a trainer
dude I'm drinking lemon water I don't
know good [__] so sour she goes she
goes drink a whole lemon squeezed into a
glass of water first thing in the
morning taste
this I've already watered it down
once it's nice I've already watered it
down once it does a little like but it's
nice I've been chugging the water but um
oh my God but I had my first day of
training yeah there you go it was such I
was such a mess good I was like just a
mess on the floor he's like come
on the trainers listen I love I the the
kid who's who's training me God bless
him but like I just I find the whole
training interaction so corny cuz at
times I'm literally a corpse on the
floor and he's like money baby you did
money like I couldn't even do it he's
like we're going to plank for 30 seconds
and then I could do like 10 he's like
money baby and I'm like I can't talk
he's like all right come on come on I'm
just ignoring him because I'm dead he's
like money baby come on baby but he
knows that he CU it doesn't actually
matter like he says do 30 seconds you do
10 I know it's good I know it's embar
I'm embarrassed and I feel like he's
being insincere no no because he I know
he's trying to encourage me but I he's
trying to encourage me but I can't
accept it I find it embarrassing you
have to accept it it's and I try to make
jokes and they don't he doesn't laugh so
because it's like it's not a laughing
matter but it is it's so pathetic he's
not being insincere though I know he's
not being you're going to get a little
bit better every time
like ever request right yeah think of it
did you fix this [__] uh try it I I
think I think so but anyway I I I can't
go up and down the stairs I
literally I have to take it one step at
a time my legs are so sore mhm I've been
there it was sad man was quite a sight
though you should wow sister
snapped that I was willing to trust too
quickly miss out on red flags and most
importantly not take the cautionary
measures that really anybody but
especially somebody with a public
platform should be taking before talking
to anybody and so is this a good legal
argument to have
judged what that he should have looked
better before engaging with sexting with
minors um your honor I I present to the
court exhibit a holding my I've held
myself accountable your honor your honor
what more do you want from me I'm a very
successful person person in my career
but when it comes to social media I just
don't know how to go to their page ah
yes yes yes yes present I was able to
find them on the social media and then
find them on Snapchat but I wasn't able
to discovered their photos so your honor
the the the defendant presents to the
course the fact that he is a a virgin
and B very desperate h
let me consider I'll need a day to
consider the uh
evidence and and is having a hard time
to find a boyfriend so interesting
compelling evidence please take that
into consideration let me consider the
evidence that when I've watched videos
in the past of people talking about
serious topics such as this one it's
always really bothered me when people
would talk about conclusions or changes
that they're going to make without
actually talking about how they got
there in the first place so I think it's
really important that I do that in this
video I just honestly think that I own
to you guys to kind of walk you through
their reflection that I've been doing um
so you know that I'm taking this
seriously how I came to terms with my
desperation and how it led me here in
2019 my dating life became even more
public than it already was when I was
called out and labed as you guys I feel
like at this point all know the story so
I don't want to go back into details but
pretty much I had to get on camera and
Diesel you're getting turned on now I
had all the receipts to back it up but
at the time I also recognized that I
definitely needed to change the way I
was going about dating because clearly
something was not working and in that
video I made a vow and a promise to
myself and to you guys as the audience
that I will be way more careful moving
forward was not one that I kept be
honest with you guys at the time that I
posted no more lies I really thought
that
so that's the video wrap it up what
what's there more another seven minutes
to talk about hey James uh Titi is
saying Tata what is what was that what
was that noise jail closing it's like a
[__] like why am I being because it
sounded like a hoer like going his I
know I'm just I was confused int sounded
like an artillery piece it is intense
and loud
what it's like a massive dungeon door it
sounds like a truck fell
over you know how hard it is to find a
jail soundbite that fast it's it's I'm
not holding against you I was just a
little confused it's like the well
you're right though we should be locking
them up like you know like they lock up
Magneto you
know like the strongest humans have ever
made actually Magneto was locked in a c
without any metal because his power is
magnetic know uh excuse me um should
have said someone else the
hater James saying use the Aon sound
bite when the start of acon song Oh the
the convict that one right I don't know
what the
[__] we'll get claim for that for sure
like just a slam all right this
let's continue holding James accountable
onlys how much more is this we got to
watch it all he asked us he said please
watch it all he said please watch my
entire confession every bit of
it so we'll do that I now realize that
it was obviously a much
deeper problem and I really wish that at
that time I had spent the time to sit
down look at myself in the mirror and
try to get to the root of the
problem why I was all myself to get into
these wish you changed back then when
you had the chance and it's a lie but
like I said I didn't and as time
progressed my desire for relationship
never really went away and I slowly
started ignoring red flags again and
also ignoring my friends and the
important people around me that warned
me that I was going to get hurt and you
were going to get hurt they were warning
you that you were going to get hurt poor
James he got h j I think he's saying un
nicely he was saying the people around
me were telling me to stop locked up
yeah I'm going to get oh that's what he
means I'm going to go to
prison yo so I hope there's like someone
at FBI who's just like mhm mhm you said
what you said people were telling you
all along okay all right what are their
names knowingly okay proceeded you've
been doing this for how long 3 years
okay
mhm I also feel like I really I want
apology
because I should have listened and I
feel like if I did we probably wouldn't
be here tday looking back now and just
trying to do my best to piece this all
together in my head I think that my lack
of experience when it came to dating
growing up and then all a a lot of
attention from different types of men
for good reasons and some for bad
reasons really affected me in ways that
I didn't quite understand keep that for
the therapist seriously bro save it for
the judge that's what they say actually
the judge doesn't give a [__] I mean you
should legitimately talk to a therapist
about that oh yeah to the [__] prison
to the prison awarded therapist you can
get therapy in prison I mean they tried
to you know they they look prison is
meant to um rehabilitate we can
rehabilitate him in prison
true honestly just thought that I had
really really bad luck and that I was
being taken advantage of when that
wasn't the case at all and I had the
mentality that I could reach out to
literally anybody page and for you page
as a dating app and eventually you know
did he really just say that he's been
taken advantage of yes and that he has
bad Lu how framing this you know what
that's CRA than my friends do this and
get away with it why do I get caught you
guys taking advantage of him Jesus what
I think James Charles is calling in
right now right now yeah I think he saw
he heard us talking [__] Ian let me know
when James is on the phone we'll P we'll
throw it to him um he like okay you guys
don't need to watch this anymore what I
wonder he oh he's like don't watch all
of it you think he's trying to stop us
embarrassing
so just throw him in when he's ready let
me know I cannot believe this James
Charles is calling into our
show while we're live reacting this is
totally unexpected well actually it is
totally expected but totally amazing
okay cool it might be there James are
you
there hi sisters
oh my God it is James
Charles um James we first of all how are
you doing in the midst of um you know
all this all this controversy it's just
you're going through a lot right
now sure there's just a lot going on
right now for me it's just a lot of
pressure this whole thing I mean it's
all bogus as you know but I'm just like
really trying to work through it
internally I feel bad for my fans
especially I let them
down yeah well do you think that
um do you think that you've done
anything wrong what do you think there's
been a lot of criticism of your video I
mean uh do you have a response to
that sure so trust me I've really grown
from reading the criticism I Now
understand that I did in fact have a bad
hair day so next right oh I don't think
next time promise I'm G to pay way more
attention to my hair I'm so sorry that I
let everyone down oh I don't think
that's what people are complaining about
he might be missing the point a little
bit I think your hair looks pretty good
well you know listen it seems like you
know in this video there's somewhat of
an admission of guilt are you afraid at
all of going to
jail look if a judge asks me about it
I've got a foolproof answer
your honor I was just down bad
oh come on James you know that doesn't
hold up in court look I guess R Kelly MJ
Woody Allen they didn't know the down
bad defense but I don't have a
choice nobody wants to date the
multi-millionaire 21-year-old celebrity
it's really hard being
me you know that is an unprecedented
argument yeah I'm the down bad argument
yeah you might have a chance there are
you
um are you uh at all surprised that you
know you you won a Nickelodeon kids
award during this whole Scandal is do
you find any irony in that or or I mean
what are well I actually think I think
it's much deserved because first of all
it's not the first time I got slimed by
a bunch of kids stop it J no James take
that back I'm kidding I'm kidding it's a
joke that is not
hard for that I worked really hard for
the award like I had to get in the mind
of a child and the DMS too stop James
stop this is inappropriate you said
there's a lot of method acting it means
so much to me that I'm up there with the
Nickelodeon great it's like Dan
Schneider oh
no J Dan you know who Dan Schneider is
right he's like he made all these
Nickelodeon cartoons and he was uh oh
God into like feet and [__] yeah not not
someone you necessarily want to be in
the company of I would say well Jesus
Christ James you're saying a lot here
seems like you've been praying on people
and you really haven't learned much I
mean how what guarantee do we have let's
say that we do forgive you that you're
going to be changing going
forward well after the tati situation it
really hurt that I was labeled a
predator right so to prove everyone
wrong I started acting like a predator
oh no as like reverse
psychology that doesn't make any sense I
don't know if that adds up so I'm very
careful now when I date I've started
checking for photo ID passport do they
have their shots tax identification
number Social Security library card two
Factor the
wordss and shots vaccination you asked
for their vaccination
records yes passport ID passport ID
vaccination records that's pretty
thorough and that's more than R Kelly
would have
asked right well AR Kelly just asked for
the passports in the shots yeah yeah
well all right well
um listen James I I don't want to take
you too long uh I don't want to keep you
on the phone too long I'm sure you have
a lot to deal with but it seems like um
you have oh what was that is there
someone at the
door oh my god oh shoot FBI open up oh
shoot someone's knocking door oh my
God
James
James oh my
God a lot of grass glass breaking he's
in a nice house he has a big nice house
wow hm
wonder if he's okay oh no what do you
think happened mat he's gone from the
call oh no
man sister snatched James Charles
everybody wow oh my God hope he's okay
that sounded dramatic yeah hope he's
okay lot of
police lot of police were
there
wow that was intense
God I'm a little spook my listening to
that oh
man oh boy do we even list keep
listening that I think we got a I think
we got the point so
embarrassing I mean that pretty much
wraps it up in federal prison sounds
like justice is being served yeah
yeah you don't want to keep watching I
mean it's
gold I feel like we have we have to keep
watching been watching for over an hour
at this point and we're oh my God six
minutes I feel this video deserves to be
dissected for every moment of
it okay you're that passionate about it
you know what for once in my life I will
I will go to the chat I will go to the
chat you want to go to the chat for once
in my life I will listen to the I
usually don't like oh you want them to
decide like I like I don't want I don't
like getting like getting the chat get
my head CU I try to just do the show and
stuff but for once I will I will do
whatever the chat feels shall we
continue or shall we move on so should I
you want a poll yeah poll let's do a
poll okay hold on I got one a poll is a
good idea
yeah you guys decide your this is just
Choose Your Own Adventure
today we finish or I pin the poll and I
am spamming it as well and it's in the
chat if you want to pull it up to see
the
results oh wait that's the wrong one
that Ian just like cuz he made one too
okay oh no give me the right one please
take oh Ian's answers were funnier we
should have done this I'm desperate
whatever I'm desperate can someone like
me please I'm begging I [__] up I'll
say yes cuz that's F whatever I just
have to vote see you guys decide don't
listen to
me and survey
says it always takes a moment Sur
says the moment of truth
is come on now with a vote of Zer to
zero maybe refresh it coming in with the
[Applause]
refresh the total vote did we crash this
cuz the linkes
working loading lo oh it's our internet
oh no our internet went out no oh
cuz I can't open wait stra did we crash
stra St did we crash their website no
there's no way straw I'm telling you
it's not loading it's not loading we
crashed their [__] site we never got
to see the results and the results
are and the drum roll please we
literally crashed
drle how is that possible people use it
all the time it's not working for every
saying it's Crash okay well well what
else can we do based on looking at the
chat it does seem divided and that's
what we need we need to know we need the
stle [__] dude some people say stop okay
wait wait we have a big segment that's
we do haveing around stra so that's a
really good point are you guys can you
guys see the result anybody that's not
here does anybody see the result can we
didn't you say we oh my God we crashed
their site we destroyed
straw we literally just destroyed well
well well guys any of you on the call
are are you all having the same issue I
think yes yeah okay yeah I can't see
[__] is there another website we can use
cuz we actually need these for our next
segment you're right Ian it's uh
unfortunate it's a divided chat though I
we are a divided chat my friends a chat
divided cannot stand I think I do see a
lot of move on yeah you would because I
think we mentioned that we have another
big segment so p. me is down for
everyone according to but the segment is
relying on straw P how are we going to
move on if we can't use the straw P
website well we have some other we don't
have to move straight into that segment
okay strule get us because it's going to
get even more intense for them coming up
in our next segment straw pull if you're
watching get your [__] together your
free damn service that I what the [__]
is there not another straw pole
website I mean I guess there probably is
but not that I know that such a classic
well all we got to fast pole.com let's
see how fast pole let's Crush fast Pole
now we got to know we need a PO that
works anyway how's everybody doing in
there live show right do it live [__]
it my God drinking this lemon juice is
killing me do it live I've got
strawberry water here my dietition my uh
I've been listening to the podcast by
the way really I'm still catching up on
Frenemies mhm but um I thought it was
funny you did it's funny you better have
be awkward if you
didn't I love the no pun intended on on
white nighting oh yeah it was so funny
Trisha goes I'm a white knight for
something no pun
intended like she was like a grand
wizard like a KKK member or something a
white um looks like uh looks like the
sight's back up drop baby let's crash
drop ble and drum roll please let's see
what do we got the website is not
[Music]
loading not load not loading again do
you see did you ever see results or
anything okay here we got a new one we
got a new one yeah I did the results
were for yes yes it's like 2/3 yes what
and yes to move wait hold on let's try
this new one try this new one stropp out
AB just put a
link the uh should we move on should we
move on
no yeah people are saying it was like
over 70% yes oh really yeah all right
[__] this then I'm
out [__] this all right bye James bye
sister Tata [__] you go to prison well
the poll was watch the rest of the video
yes or no wait wait wait
what that's what I thought I wanted to
finish it I thought it was should we
move on oh it was worded so they it said
watch the rest of video want me to
finish
it right you're going to see
confused okay they want me to finish the
video what did they want it
unfortunately sound yeah that's what
he's saying yes yes overwhelming
majority wants to finish the video like
myself want to Spook I'm going to do
James Charles all thank you Paul crazy
okay yeah I just loaded it it's
73%
73% what the hell can I take a moment to
Bass oh watch the rest of the video I
want to see okay here let's see the
results wait so what did I just mess
that up no AB sent one that said Mo
on oh yeah it's 7 75% finished we love
our we love our audience all right why
you guys all over it and I'm like
totally into it because when more are we
going toct over every second Dan is
always wanting to move on always the
next thing always the next thing Dan why
can't you just be present in the moment
because we plan a ton of good content
for today and we've already spent like
an hour and a half picking over six
minutes of this [__] idiot's video
let me get my thoughts together
here well I will say from the crew poll
80% s move on yeah
lucky my sh
[__] I will milk this [__] I know
what the people want D people want to
watch James
get locked
up all you guys really against finish
the video who voted who voted to I want
to talk about Fe who voted to watch who
voted to
watch out of the US okay whatever let's
just watch the [__] video that's what
the people want oh God I can't hear
anymore wish that at that time I had
spent the time to sit down but like I
said I didn't and as time progressed my
desire for relationship never really
went away and I slowly started ignoring
red flag that sounds weird it's like my
desire for young boys my desire for
relationship you clearly were not
looking for a desire you were looking
for a momentary release of a
jizz God gross but seriously that's what
he's doing he was he had his own
personal you know
Hub um James Hub I'm going to come he
called what was that that's Trump oh
that was Donald Trump saying I'm gonna
come I'm gon to
come yeah and also ignoring my friends
and the important people around me that
warned me that I was going to get hurt
and yeah where where we were to them I
also feel like I really owe an apology
because I should have listened and I
feel like if I did we probably wouldn't
be here today looking back now and just
trying to do my best to piece this all
together in my head I think that my lack
of experience when it came to dating
growing up and then all of a sudden
having a lot of attention from different
types of men some for good
reason really affected me in ways that I
didn't quite
understand exactly that's what the real
like exactly oh oh my childhood and I
did the day
did you bring
condoms perfect sound I honestly just
thought that I had really really bad
luck and that I was being taken
advantage of when that wasn't the case
at all I can't stop everything he says
is such [__] such so
bad I was being manipulated that these
by these beautiful boys these beautiful
little 15 and 16year old boys and
everyone tried to warn me that I was
going to get hurt oh yeah he makes it by
himself not that you're shouldn't be
flirting with what about hurting
traumatizing AO people I'm actively
searching for younger people to be in a
relationship with right and I had the
mentality that I could reach out to
literally anybody and use my explore
page and for you page as a dating app
and eventually I would just happen to
find the right person but that's just
not how dating Works literally seriously
be making this argument after weird and
his whole stating strategy from what
I've seen of the pics which you haven't
seen they're out there I mean read them
or not they're pretty graphic but he
goes it's all about like like uh satisfy
and block satisfy himself and block it's
like Scorch Earth it's like find new
prey satisfy himself and block I mean
bro is not looking for a
relationship Vin
Diesel I would Vin Diesel is more
Charming than James Charles at this
point someone saved me oh
yeah it's desperation I just really
thought it was important to share my
thought
having with Andals behind the scenes to
help fully understand the situation so I
could properly hold accountable for how
I got the weirdest confession to a when
these vide started to come toay power
imbalance became a really large
topic as if it was some other kind of
like Creator on Creator drama and he's
like I'm just going to hold myself
accountable right but it's like no this
is a crime it goes back to what we said
in the beginning it's like he thinks
he's being cancelled
no you're not being cancelled yeah you
should be
arrested this is not this has nothing to
do with being cancelled you're right
that's what he thinks is happening and
rightfully so in 2019 that I had
my the truck just fell over whole
situation I was accused of abusing my
fame money and power to get what I
wanted and when I responded to that at
the time I said that that was disgusting
and that I would never want to do that
and to this day I still stand behind
that sentiment 1,000% so when it was
getting brought up again I got really
really frustrated and was trying to
understand because I was thinking to
myself like okay I know that this
situation shouldn't have happened I know
that I this conversation shouldn't have
occur this is him in therapy he's
basically in therapy Mount I'm going to
role play as this therapist ability for
that but at the same time like they dmed
you first they lied to you they flirted
first like you didn't use your fame
money and power to get anything but I've
now realized that mentality is
completely wrong because a power
imbalance can happen even when it's not
intentional bro shut the [__] up about
power and balance you know exactly what
you're doing exhibit a once again let me
just go back to this clip from um the
impulsive show where they were
like uh here power Dynamic okay does
this this is from like when was this
podcast why don't you come visit like
well I can't afford to some who doesn't
understand power dnamic I can so like
get on the plane and like well I just
don't really feel comfortable with that
but like I love you and I really want to
be together and I'm like well well we
can't be together because you can't
afford a plane ticket you're probably
still in either high school or college
like senior in high school or in college
so like either you accept the flight and
realize that like this is what I'm
bringing to the relationship why don't
you come visit like well I can't afford
a plane ticket imag to come visit him
they must be scared or
uncomfortable like obviously there's a
reason they want to come visit you
James also
um right this guy understands power
Dynamic trust me also the kids that he
followed were following him they were
friends of his that's why he followed
him he was clearly using his fans you
know he knows what he's doing this is a
predator who has manipulated who
successfully manipulated his fans who
are
incapable of critical thought because
they're too young and is somehow Star
Struck when he reaches out to them right
and this this apology video is just
genuinely shocking on so many
levels um I mean it's a confess it's a
straight up
confession wrapped in [__] squired in
some David D perfume or some [__] David
what David doic have perfume like that
was another weird one that he did to
make money I think we ever talked about
that on Miss The Mark with that one did
we never ever did we never talk about
David do perfume no what the [__] was
with him making a perfume like what is
he known for smelling good or something
it's just I mean whatever it's like
merch I guess
yeah all right well I'm well I'm going
to make perfume it's going to called
smells like my
butthole oh did you see that uh Chanel
or something actually came out with it
smells like
beach there was this Seinfield episode
where Kramer made this perfume smells
like beach someone actually did that
anyway sorry deep
cut not now I wasn't getting before is
that the excitement that comes with
talking to a celebrity is literally to
make do or say something that they
wouldn't even if that celebrity isn't
intentionally weaponizing their fame
money or power and that's the concept
that I just wasn't getting but I now do
even though I'm able to turn off my
social media and just talk to somebody
outside of the spotlight about something
normal in normal clothes and no makeup
on as James Dickinson that doesn't
change the fact that to them I'm still
James Charles and that's something that
I can't turn off for me having a public
platform has become such a huge part of
my life that at this point it does feel
normal but I have to understand that to
99.9% of people it's not normal it will
never be normal and that's where the
power and balance lies I understand but
I'm so glad that I finally do because
like I said 201 soad had fully
enlightened now guys but it's like fully
enlightened now I mean you weren't able
to understand this basic concept so what
else are you not understanding right now
that we'll find out in 3 years wow you
know good
Insight I'm so glad I had this in this
immediate Epiphany uh morph called me
I'm calling the
morph morph called me this morning and I
had an immediate Epiphany I was totally
enlightened I've had three years to
think about
it
confiscate his [__] hard drive FBI
right
now to do but unintentionally was with
this situation blowing up there are a
lot of people speaking about this online
whether it be sharing their opinions
arguing back and forth or most
importantly holding me accountable for
my actions I understand that posting
this video today is not going to stop
those conversations but is going to
spark more of them and that's something
that I am completely okay with because I
really feel like these are top tocs that
we need to be speaking about a lot more
I also want to make it clear too that
through uploading this video today my
hope and my expectations are not to you
know press post and then forget about it
and move on and wash my hands as if
nothing happened because something did
happen and what happened was not okay
and I don't want to just forget about it
um I should have been more careful every
single way when it comes to the ways
that I was looking for relationship I
didn't do the proper search and for that
I'm once again a how is there more how
is there 3 minutes more [__] up go talk
to the therapist this is not therapy bro
you're talking to like 12-year-old girls
like this is not
James
boys this video is crazy to me
everything I mean look at the like
ratio look at the like ratio all the
comments now are ironic and stuff but in
the
beginning uh it was all like like we
love a mature James we love mature James
taking a
responsibility crazy man but I am really
really glad that I now fully understand
the situation so I'm able to do better
in the future
and I really hope to show that to you
guys yeah you could show us to imprison
this is the part where he goes like I
still plan on having a career I still
plan on being here we're going to get
over through this together he should not
have a career he should not have a
YouTube Channel he should not have
social media he should be in jail and
off the
internet and locked in a dungeon far
under the earth made of molten Stone
forged from the what the what's wait
what was that what was the tank I played
the I I had a video for uh that sound
effect that Zach keeps playing oh Jesus
Dan showing like military
[__] okay James continue I'm a firm
believer that when scandals or
situations like this happen you can get
on camera and upload an apology video
where you say sorry a million times all
day long but the only way to actually
show and prove that you are sorry is
through action and change and I'm going
to change this whole situation has been
soarring yeah go change it's none of our
business anymore exactly what you're
saying you didn't do go [__] change
on your own time bro prove it to
yourself cuz I nobody get I I mean
nobody should care at this point it's
like BR you're done done but like I said
I'm now educated and fully understand
now educated and iing a promise all of
you right now on camera that I will be
way more careful moving forward with
every single person that I speak to so
again he's not even pledging to stop
once again yeah he's just pledging right
here now on camera right before you to
do a little more research by myself at
1:00 a.m. in this room
you're going to see the power of God
that I will not stop basically I will
not stop I pledge to you right now peace
and love peace and love peace and love
for you page and explor Page are not
dating apps and I will stop treating
them as if they are I also have already
started asking for proper identification
from every single guy that has either
reached out or that I was speaking to
and we'll continue doing so for the rest
of time no don't no no no no no no no no
no
no he's not stopping do you hear him
yeah he is not stopping all he's saying
is I'll do a little more
research but do you know how easy it is
to photoshop a [__] ID online
especially these kids they're like
Geniuses they know they're like kids who
grow up these days they could like
Photoshop a [__] they could like
print counterfeit money if they wanted
to these kids are
crazy you think they can't like change
one digit on
ID not that James would look that hard
it' be all like scratched out like the
seven would be like a nine he' be like
looks good
sister he's not he's pledging he is
pledging to you all now on camera not to
stop I Now understand the root of the
problem I understand how and why I and
only I caus myself to get into this
situation I understand that this could
have and should have been easily avoided
and I also understand that I need to be
aware of my platform at theenda all
times I didn't understand how a
situation like this could affect the
people involved but now I do and for
that to the victims I am so so sorry
block he's like I'm so so sorry blocked
how many people do you think he has
blocked I'd like to see his block
list and I promise that something like
this will FBI if you're watching start
with his block list if you want to find
his
victims just go through everyone he's
blocked on Snapchat never ever happen
again I also feel like I owe an apology
to my friends family team members and
also fans that had to watch this all go
down again to all of you guys I once
again wish that I had listened earlier
on um apologize to the victims he didn't
apologize to me oh he did the
viewers he did he apologized to the
victims yeah he did at the very
beginning oh yeah let's go back for ELA
oh
no you guys saw this and I didn't and
I'm really really sorry for not taking
that seriously and not oh no being a
better person and a better role model
like I promised that I would be I'm
going to be taking some time away oh
hair did like a his hair shifted to one
side he took a moment to do his hair
interesting what do we think about this
he didn't have his Glam team there yeah
it's all falling apart reflect and
further educate myself on these topics I
think at this point it's really
important that I do so so I'm able to
follow through with my word and prove to
you guys that I will be a better person
even though I won't be here posting I do
want people to know that I will still be
here available listening and learning
here learn the bro bro learn from the
warrant when it served you bro if he
doesn't go to jail if he continues to
have a career then everything that the
world has been through with this whole
matu and all this Assault Awareness and
all is literal [__] meaningless trash
if James goes on to have a career if he
keeps doing tick Tok dances with the
demilios you know what I mean if he's
still hanging out with no dragon or
whatever is is that her name noia Dragon
she likes James um if people keep
associating and he keeps making
videos then we are all doomed I mean
that's it there's just this will always
happen there's no solution spook Mago at
this point you Deb all the way through
the video I really appreciate [__]
grueling dude I wish I I wish I would
have listened to you guys
thank you for listening and I hope to
never disappoint you again see you soon
okay well basically basically it's like
there's nothing there's not much to say
about it the guy he's admitting to
crimes and everything else is [__]
[__]
yeah pretty much you can't keep getting
away with it so let me ask you guys now
at this point what do you think's going
to happen to James Charles
nothing
really no nothing I agree yeah I agreee
with Eli I don't think a [__] thing's
going to happen yeah so great but as
[__] up as that sounds I don't want to
talk about James Charles anymore I don't
I swear to God I don't no one's forcing
you well we did I mean you don't have to
talk about him every week yeah well
[__] am I supposed to every week what
am I supposed to do as like a
responsible member of this
community it's going to happen again
there's going to be more allegations
that come up I guarantee you
oh it's funny cuz it's so sad
yeah
yeah you I mean but there's I guess it's
just up to if the parents press charges
or something right cuz one of the kids
posted that his parents were pressing
charges I'm
desperate your
honor I'm desperate so I listen you want
me just to never talk about it again Dan
is that your solution just forget James
Charles exists here on YouTube what if
you had a child who was a fan of James
Charles what what are you ask
what sorry we can talk about him I mean
whatever anyway that's it there's really
nothing else to say about it you all
know you all know what it is I'm really
excited about this next segment though
let's have fun let's switch gears a
little
bit little bit spook maged for my
Tastee was that spook M it's rewind time
all right can I use the bathroom if you
go to the bathroom I'll play a um I'll
set this up for
you today ladies and gentlemen is the
soundbite Olympics World
Championship favorite here let me pull
this up this is amazing here's the tier
list we've got all of our favorite sound
bites this is
the [__] oh let me send you the link
yeah send me the
link this is just
images we've got little xan pulling a
gun we've got yeah you better just send
me the
the thank
you oh what is this website
challenge here here's the bracket oh
this is beautiful baby this is [__]
glorious so we are going to play one for
one we're going to show you the origin
which one did you say got claimed Zach
did you take it out the first one the
Joker one um it got claimed we use that
all the time well the video clip of the
or that makes sense so we'll just play
the sound bite okay so we've got Joker
oh we're putting the the
laughs Joker Laugh Bry scum laugh white
CA Gabe a new introduction Trisha [__]
UAB I want to smell feet shout out to
the family we have 30 Oh I thought there
was 32 you reduced a little bit there
are 32 there are only c16 there are two
in each uh thing oh math let's
go let's just get right into it with the
first and so you guys know how the
bracket works so not only are we going
to be voting live we're also going to be
getting a little bit of a history on all
of our favorite sound bites as well so I
mean this this is this is I honestly I
love so many of these I I couldn't
possibly predict which way this is going
to
go but I am excited so excited Carlo I
love Carlos but I think people hate
Carlos based on what I've heard so round
one right off the bat go ahead and play
us these the two uh sound bites here uh
Zach if you would please we've got go
ahead that is the classic Jared Leto
Joker Sound by
it hits perfectly it's powerful we love
it but on the other hand we've got the
rice
gum the rice gum laugh is so iconic so
why don't you throw up a
pole and I'll show the
origins so you guys vote on which
one is the more Superior sound
bite oh oh rice got made a video about
me I forgot that's so funny oh this
YouTuber m is lying to you and he made
fun of your laugh this was D this was
like the biggest F in history Mon Mon
over here even his own fans downloaded
the [__] out of this video man rice
gum so he was making fun of ela's laugh
which as you know you can't go after
Queen Ela wait so the laugh sound bite
is from this video yeah yeah oh so here
it is so good give you a little context
on this is like a dream job and people
would probably want to be in his shoes
so he need to chill out like I'm really
try to think I'm not a therapist or
anything and this is oh yeah he was
making fun of me for being depressed or
something towards the end of the video
so a lot of people might not even see
this so I'm just going to say how it is
I think this fool is depressed or
whatever because his girl be just so
whack like I'm sorry someone has to say
it but like every time his girl is in a
video bro it's just crickets so just go
just walk into the house
and look through their [__] and find
guns mono told Monica over here no I'm
just kid I so that's that
I mean wow wow wow wow wow it's hard to
top that honestly I forgot that that's
where it came from also funnny enough he
used a clip of you talking about
something serious from the podcast I
know about something so serious it's
like okay we can't show you the Jared
letter one cuz it's from a movie they'll
claim us but go ahead and play the Joker
give us some Joker but you can show like
a him in the trailer or something no I
can't even show that no really give me
all the Joker
ones ah
got the
ah I mean that's
good play machine gun play rice gun one
more
time all right so the so so um where do
I see the results uh I'm looking at it
um can you put it on screen or do I have
to you have to so so do I have so
someone send me the
link
okay it's also pinned in the chat so you
guys just send me the send me the link
when we go to a new round now I don't
want to vote I don't want to
um so well you should do it off oh you
don't have to I thought you have oh wow
a close
one very close jars like Jared Leto is
uh interesting edging out a little bit
okay so we have a first bracket winner
congratulations to Jared let Joker I got
to say I kind of agree like the rice gum
story is so good that sound bite but
then the Jared L one like always makes
me laugh whenever Zach uses it I always
laugh I can't control it so are you able
to update this bracket is that how that
works yeah will you'll do it do I here
do I have to update it or okay this is
going to appear in live uh like we're
going to see the changes that's so cool
yeah yeah yeah we'll see the changes
live cool all right next up we've got an
actually a new entry white claw Gabe
Fried Chicken Wednesday a new personal
favorite of mine and Trisha um which
doesn't have a link in here [__] you AB
I think it's just a sound bite go ahead
and hit me with the sound bite if you
would please that [__] Wednesday
night baby [__] Fried Chicken love it
epic and then F
AB the [__] you AB is
truly truly an iconic sound bite [__]
you AB yeah it's so powerful too there's
so much Gusto behind it go ahead play it
again for me Zach [__] you AB [__] [__]
she hits that Fu she hits that [__] hard
you know what I'm saying [__] you at the
same time let's not discount Fu let's
not discount our boy gab Fried Chicken
Wednesday
baby
[__] yeah Fried Chicken Wednesday
baby yeah fucking's one of my favorite
nights because a fried chicken yeah
[__] Wednesday night baby [__]
fried chicken you got to show the V yep
Fried Chicken Wednesday Fried Chicken
Wednesday who deserves Fried Chicken me
me I deserve Fried Chicken Wednesday
Wednesday Fried Chicken Chien G I mean
listen this is a it's an obvious blowout
this is a blow it's a complete yeah you
just announce it Dan it's Trisha by
Trisha 0% yeah love the white claw G
Gabe it's a newent also like the usage
of the Sound by like when ever Zach uses
it as soon as AB talks It's the funniest
[__] but where was that from the [__]
you AB was that from her video about him
right yeah was about her her r as
everybody well remembers uh not
something we like to necessarily bring
up but um but you know when when you
come across a sound bite like that it
just you know natural well I mean the
vote speaks for itself 90% right so AB
how does it feel to uh win this this
round round I'm
oned next uh next round is going to be a
tough one I I have a hard time
predicting this cuz these are two
Slammers moving on Wow we have Ela I
want to smell feet first shout out to
the family whoa that's this could easily
be a championship bracket yeah that's
really tough um Ela I want to go ahead
Zach I want to smell feet oh such a
great sound bite now we all know that's
a deep fake um no it's not I have the
clip right here here let me pull up the
context what is the origin of that it
should say dude that's a good I want to
smell feet I want to smell feet is
pretty fun why did I say go back
more it should say dude that's a good I
want to smell
feet why did say crystal clear evidence
you who put this
together
well there's no context that's just what
it is conveniently you guys did not
include the cont I mean this isn't a
deep fig you said it so how that how
that came to be was um there was a sound
bite of Dan saying I want to talk about
feet right like about a year ago yeah
and um I would just play it and then the
wiki feet thing came to be and then it
just kind of took off so I think just El
you just had feet on your mind you want
to smell feet I don't I want to smell
feet okay a very strong entry but
honestly the next one has
become such a staple of the show it's so
powerful it's it's gone beyond the show
I feel like shout out to their families
like it's kind of become a meme even in
like the chat and stuff it's like a show
meme shout out to your family go ahead
Zach please shout out to his
family now the now of course the origin
story is really what's so funny about
this is that this guy David gut or
whatever he was making a tribut to David
G Gua Gua he was making a tribute to J
George
Floyd and uh this was his shout out to
George Floyd who was violently murdered
by a police officer this was his tribute
to his and shout out to his family
difficult times and America too
[Music]
actually so last night I knew we were
going to do this we going to do this and
I made a special record so this
record is in honor of George
Floyd and I really hope we can see more
unity and more peace HP when already
things are so difficult so difficult
he's right so shout out to his
family and then like I'm going to mute
it like oh does he play Martin Luther
King drop yeah yeah yeah more MLK
drop oh even though we Face the
difficulties and he to be I still have a
dream it is a dream out to his in the
American dream here it
is I have a
dream look at this
let's go shout out to the family shout
out to his
family I'm sorry Ela but this one is so
iconic I have to agree with you but it's
up to the people it's not up to
us Dan do we have a vote well are we
calling it cuz it's it's been neck and
neck oh really like really really close
and actually went back and forth a few
times but it looks like shout out to his
family is just barely edging it out
let's pull it up this is interesting
yeah this I'm telling you this is this
one could was actually in the lead for a
bit but it seems to have reverse now so
this could have been a championship
bracket I swear to God this is this is a
tough
matchup shout out to his family I love
that it's just so versatile yeah and as
much as I love I want to smell feet yeah
it's a it's just it's so tough It's just
such a tough competition you
know well David GAA I think the people
have spoken at this point but
wow just barely I'm glad it was a close
one 54% say shout out to the family 46%
say I want to smell feet so that was
shout out to his family by far the
closest matchup we've had
today um next
up Trump okay and go ahead and play them
we've got Trump okay versus reporter
saying uh DD Mega doodoo okay
versatile used frequently personal
favorite of mine I mean even backstage
were frequently just being okay okay I
say it all the time I find myself saying
it all the time on and off the show okay
okay on the other hand Zach DD Mega dooo
also pretty iconic especially with
Ethan's that's a long Runner too I mean
that's we've had that one for years at
this point classic it's a classic you
know
um there's really no video the footage
to show it's just it is what it is at
this point right is there footage for
Trump it's just him going okay I mean
you know he always talks like a
maniac um I think that's from a it was a
hot mic if I'm not mistaken oh right he
finished like State of the Union and was
like okay
here if we have it I would want to watch
it yeah I do have it oh okay okay
oh it's
muted that is actually a great one
okay that is
powerful quick
okay
okay [__] what is
that wow it's even better than I thought
it would be yeah that was pretty good
and then you have me to say their final
goodbyes to this Fallen Louisville
police officer DD she died do I'm sorry
that makes it funnier she's paying
tribute to a poor officer who died in
the line of duty but it's funny that you
see how it's spelled and it get not even
close menot menot men
menot that's a [__]
crazy look how she says it to say their
final goodbyes to this Fallen Louisville
police officer DD Mega dooo I'm sorry
menoo sorry I'm sorry Mega
Doo d d so obviously both are really
strong contenders and both extremely
strong as crashed what crashed it's
working for the link oh it's working
seems like of all day straw pole does
seem to be you know running a little
shitty you know I I frequently uh have
trouble speaking and so the d d Mega
dudo certainly comes in
handy on those days for the
guys um another close one another really
close one another close one let's view
the
results trumpy is uh is winning though
yeah it's such a good that is just such
a well-used and well- loved s by yeah so
let's call it for Trump I think I think
Trump's got it Trump okay well
congratulations to Trump he's back he's
back can we see it one more time with
the video you want to watch Trump again
sure El of course anything you
want I do want anything for you
okay
okay it's like I've never seen anyone
say okay like that it's like
so it's like so bo bo
bous
okay
okay it's just a whole bed okay oh
[Laughter]
okay good Cho I think that was the right
choice yeah well well voted people next
up James Charles oh no wow vers the
Seaman pasture Seaman is just a type of
me seen Pastor is very recent only from
like three weeks ago but so good has
really has really shot up the rankings
go ahead with the oh no please um oh no
as you guys well know that is a favorite
on this show
yeah do we have the footage of that one
we don't have the footage of that
one actually of the oh no yeah yeah we
couldn't figure out where that came from
I'm sure somebody in
the it would have been good to see but
well you guys know it you love it here
is the the Sean is is another kind of
milk it's something that's for context
for those that don't know this is a
pastor who's he's very anti-gay but very
Pro consuming semen I know it's hard to
understand he want to put it in his
coffee yeah he he he he loves seen and
he has a conspiracy that Starbucks
coffee is so good because they put human
semen in
it coffee I told him to keep his
offerings uh but at any rate the Sean is
is another kind of
milk is something that's
produced by the testical glands of a man
and then let let's hear glands of a man
he James one more
time oh
no oh
no h oh
no all right let's see the results I
think I know how this is going to go
yeah that's what I se is is another kind
of milk you know I we're doing it on the
James Charles episode it was a bias
think I don't think so I don't think
there's a bi oh no is very versatile
though I think it Oho has its rightful
place in the shows
yeah oh no yeah I think that's right all
right we're lining up round six here all
right we're making progress here guys
this we're coming down to a
showdown okay quartering I just peed in
my basement oh yeah oh yeah versus Dan
honestly oh don't give it to me come on
the pee in the
basement come on people I mean I don't
want to Poison the Well too much peed in
my basement the quaring on stream was
angry at his wife for going to Pizza
without him he got extremely drunk on
stream and he was too occupied playing
video games to go upstairs and use a
bathroom so he peed in his basement and
announced it on stream here you
are but I'm ready I'm ready
now you pass it oh oh I did
I've never lost that
round I've never lost that
round
grunting but I'm ready I'm ready
now
where my God there's Pete in my basement
oh
yeah
so the quarter I mean yeah peed in his
basement peed in my basement peed in my
basement
yeah and you know I mean we love it we
love it for sure it's
great up
next Dan's honestly another widely use
sound B honestly do you like living with
someone Dan or do you prefer to have
your own place I understand you're being
economical but it's like God you know
you shouldn't have to live with someone
put some money aside yeah do you like
living with someone or do you prefer to
have your own place I mean yeah I prefer
but that's wait what
happened whatever you guys don't need to
see the origin you get it it's dancing
on
honestly I mean right there's nothing
interesting about that clip I think he
was saying it a lot or something at the
time which is why it became that thing
yeah it was more of the repeated use
than any one particular uh but this
one's a blowout uh I'm it's it's the
quartering it is yeah yeah like 70% I
mean I think that honestly is a little
bit of an older meme at this point yeah
honestly yeah that's true I mean but but
like the I just peed in my basement I
mean come on that's power that's a power
that's what I mean it's just it's a
lopsided it's a
Powerhouse yeah that's like a yeah so
congratulations quartering jery if
you're watching this um we know you are
we know wife went out for pizza without
me so
congratulations here's an interesting
one Ian I got a pie so bad yeah iconic
iconic but old yeah it's another oldie
go ahead Zach I got a piece so bad yeah
Ian used to always take pea breaks or so
the joke went and um D Dan are you
spamming all I can hear is Dan spamming
the are you st stop spamming the pole I
know but can someone ban Dan someone B
seriously like I can't hear anything
over Dan spamming contr
B can you do it quieter can you be more
subtle about
it um so I got to PE so bad vers Ace
family stop I mean let's be honest folks
go ahead and play that the story of I
got a pee so bad for people who don't
know um we kept wanting Zach to do sound
bites but it was like the very
beginning of the idea of it yeah how are
you talk to me
I'm doing swell you know life is uh good
that's why are you does it sound like
you're being ironic I got a pee so
bad oh so we thought we thought Ian
really said
it and that and it was a sound bite and
I was
like uh I don't know it was very odd it
was one of the first times Zach ever
used a sound bite and we thought Ian had
actually said it and we were I think it
was the The First Time Zack ever Sound
by did a sound by yeah I I I owe you a
lot man because I birthed into a
beautiful thing well we were at first I
was kind of like why did you do that I
was like confused and it took me a
moment to realize the genius of it and
we had this whole conversation about why
did you choose that one because it just
seemed so Random so that turned into a
whole thing the still survives today so
Zach you are I got to PE so bad Zach you
are ahead of your time can I say thank
you I appreciate it and stop on the
other hand you have the ace family stop
which as you guys know stop one of my
favores so the ace family was doing some
kind of absolute Shenanigans where he
was had a jet ski in his pool
pool and you can see his neighbor he's
kicking down so much muddy water into
the neighbor's yard and he's screaming
at him to
stop
[Applause]
look how they're destroying the [__]
neighborhood it's just
awesome stop so so and then finnally
enough wait that that was it yeah that
was it oh my God it sounds like a sound
bite to me now
like but what's so funny is if you go to
the jet ski video at the right moment
and turn it up all the way you can hear
the neighbor screaming stop that was the
best that was the best Discovery oh
there it is go ahead
Zach you hear that so I mean I don't
know man this this to me is one of the
best ever and uh but hey it's not up to
me is it folks well it seems like the
audience agrees cuz it is uh it is
winning handily results are
in 7030 that seems to be the
blowout you know I got a piece so bad
was is is an iconic sound bite but it's
an old it's been a while yeah stop is
just it's one of those revolutionary
discoveries
stop you know and it's just so good I
got to pee so bad rest in peace rest in
pee that will forever hold a a special
place in my heart yeah mine too mine too
Papa John Pizza is actually very
nutritious versus Carlos B connect
H Um Papa you we don't have a a clip for
Papa's very nutritious that was is
actually very nutritious yeah he came on
the show we were interviewing Papa was a
very exciting time and he said to me I
was like listen you're making people fat
or something I don't know and he's like
well actually Pizza is very nutritious I
was like Papa Pizza is actually very
nutritious stop come on Papa like the
pizza
papaganda the pizza papaganda
you know it's a great line and so but
then then on the other hand you got
Carlos who's a living legend living
meme one of the greatest heyy big
connect was a Ponzi scheme or was it
just straight up scam yeah it was a
Ponzi
scheme uh during the clim when
when car I don't know Carlos sound bites
to me are are every green legendary and
uh I know some people are annoyed but
Carlos to me is an absolute Legend This
Guy's actually just being scammed he's
not this guy actually just thought he
was going to he was making a bunch of
money with bit connect he didn't realize
he was being scammed I think yeah and
helping scam others probably but his
enthusiasm is unbelievable I want him to
be my hype man he could be my play all
day hey hey hey everybody my name is
Carlos Matos and I am coming from New
York City New York let me tell you guys
that I am so excited I am so happy I am
really so thrilled to be right now
sharing this amazing glorious everything
super and exciting moment of my life
with all of you guys and let me tell you
that we are really changing the
world the world is not anymore the way
you used to
be
be this guy thought he was going to
become a millionaire by doing nothing
that's why he's so
excited be and there's a part about his
wife right my wife no my wife doesn't
believe in we are coming and we are
coming in
waves we are starting and we are going
to actually go all of the world we are
belting the entire
world let me tell you you guys that I
started
137 days ago with only $
25,6 and right now I am reaching
$140,000 w w what's
up I and let me tell you that I am
actually earning around 100 I mean
around
$1,400 on an everyday basis 7even days a
week
what
I am right now
independently financially independently
I am saying to so many people who said
that this was going to be a corn arst
game that this was going to be a scammer
game hey you're going to lose all your
money my wife still doesn't believe in
me I'm telling him b list this is real
no no no no no no that's a
scam and I said but wait I'm going to go
to the bank I'm going to get my B coins
I'm going to putting $ do here there
right on the table a that's money that
you took from another account I'll say
what am I going to do he's so upscript
then I said to him I said you know what
ready to him up
stage no more about scam people in the
crowd are like wait hold on they say
what y y y okay that's
real so guys I want to tell you
something
faith and belief is the one thing that
we all need to be able to change the
world and right now I believe this room
we
have that's to anyway there's so many
it's going to
explode into an amazing opportunity for
us to change this entire world I am so
proud I am so honored I am so excited to
be here right now and let me tell you
something that each and every one of you
has the opportunity to be come like
those amazing people that we know here
from Vietnam he my
Vietnam so much money that they
can so guys let me tell you I
love be
connect yes thank you so much does he do
Bar Mitzvah man
yeah that's a blowout for our boy
[Applause]
be and I mean listen shout out to Carlos
because that is staying power that is an
old sound bite that has stayed relevant
yeah and even become even more relevant
recently with all people some people in
the chat are new to this video together
oh for real I did a whole video about it
on h3h3 it's really old your classic man
thank you appreciate that I agree with
you sorry January 2018
goad sorry go ahead I agree with you it
had like a Resurgence with the whole n
yeah like when we were selling the nfts
I mean the big connect [__] was cracking
me up yeah so congratulations to Carlos
real steering power people real okay oo
it's another 7030 I
think
still what Dan spaming at least I can't
hear it loud last time Dan was
like all right next up we have Steven
Seagal Vladimir Putin Vladimir Putin oh
we've got coffee delivery
oh thank you so much thank you yes I
love that thank you Elizabeth everybody
bringing us coffee we love it folks
don't
we he hey hey Dan do you want a coffee
no wow you want a coffee don't be shy
okay all
right that was that was an unexpected uh
surprise thank you ELO and Elizabeth you
messaged her yeah
Legend I saw some of the guys like
drinking stuff and I was like more
coffee so we've got Vladimir
Putin who is of course step Vladimir
who's just talking totally
normally why don't we really and then he
drops like the biggest sank on Vladimir
Putin's
name to be honest here Pierce let's
let's be really
honest uh every country is involved in
Espionage every single country the
American spy the British spy the Russian
spy we all Spy on each other let's be
honest however for anyone to think that
that Vladimir Putin had uh sorry what
like all of a sudden he put the most
respect on a name I ever heard in my
life Vladimir Putin like bro that is I
never heard so much respect on a name in
my whole damn life Vladimir Putin
Vladimir Putin Vlad Vladimir
Putin however for anyone to think that
Vladimir Putin had uh uh anything to do
with fixing the elections or man it's
like he has to pause before he says it
to like character also that's so bizarre
how epic is it that stepen Seagal is out
here doing PR for Vladimir Putin it's so
crazy I love it Vladimir Putin Putin
that's that's iconic I mean for me I
love it but the competition is stiff
because up against it is Will Smith's
classic o yeah
yeah is are we doing is it the ah or the
yah I'm confused I think it's a a
package it's the whole will rewind time
package got
it no it's rewind time I don't know man
you know if I control rewind I would
want fortnite fortnite and marz brownley
Marquez brownley dude I think nothing
will
oh
no what is this wait what is this stand
stupid meme at it yeah
so I mean play all the ones we
have give me a fortnite fortnite yeah
fortnite that's hot it's rewind time is
that's hot from that that's hot that's
hot yeah it is too oh that's hot oh
that's hot that that is the def
of prolific I mean wow the memes that
sprung from that Year's rewind have it's
the remember everybody was so mad about
it it's like that was that was the best
rewind we were ever going to get and
then and then they didn't do it and it
was so sad so right everybody you
everybody complained so much they
stopped making but it was they didn't
know it was the best one ever Casey nice
day I told you guys they tried to get me
in there doing like the [__]
jig with some makeup beauty artist you
could have been in the most iconic M
video of all time you miss your CH I
said [__] no I don't want to be in that
[__] I'll watch it well listen this is
another this is another no-brainer it's
a total blowout Will Smith yeah has
taken it congratulations wils it's
rewind time it is rewind time ah yeah
fortnite yeah and shout out to Z Zach
has really made I feel like those Will
Smith sound bites are basically part of
your fingers at this point they they
really
are like it's just it's just part of
your language we totally talking s biit
now yeah that's what's like happening
that happens to me like the like I'll
get up be like yeah just like you can
use it on anything like literally yeah
man that was that that to me is the peak
of his
career of Will Smith Will Smith
I honestly don't think that it gets
better than that I really don't that's H
so shout out okay moving on we've got uh
something is about the bus a new entry
versus Wendy William fart
oh about the is like uh I think this is
Kenneth Copeland's chir Ministry I don't
know if we know what Ministry no I think
no I think it was it was oh yeah I think
we discovered that it was sh the soil so
we just thought this great for
obvious J is about the
bu just the word
bu there's no hardore to PR in the Holy
Ghost come on come
on mean this guy go do a whole Ser about
how Lil na X is
demonic is about to BU
at least little n having sex with the
devil you know I mean this guy's trying
to [__]
God Seaman is just another type of
milk sorry he Li okay so Seaman is is
another kind of why does she sound like
Kermit the Frog like that guy's voice he
is Kermit we drank
beer oh K cuz he you like beer cator he
kind of has voice thing having some
beers with friends you like beers
Senator okay something is about the bust
versus fa at 27 years old you're old
enough to understand political
correctness in the times that we live
now you can't just slap people on the
booty of course he probably knows it's
not right from a man to a woman or a
woman to a man but you can't even do
that locker room thing that cop wasn't
playing that I mean you're looking you
this is where it get interesting that's
the quiet one that's what it sounded
like but was we were able to isolate and
boost without altering the said all and
Zach please play me what you found I
will be
honored a
pure undoctored Wendy William fart
that's like a fart sound bite that you
could upload to like a sound bite
Library yeah audio audiol library.com
audio jungle totally audio jungle dude
she ripped ass so hard live and I loved
every minute of it but it's up to you
guys and uh let's a little bit uh I
would
say potentially what you would call an
upset on this one I think I'm witnessing
our first upset May looks like something
is about to bust has it wow this is not
what I expected is about to bust it's
[__] good though I mean I get it I
get it I love it I got to say I'm
surprised this is a bit of an upset it's
such humor isn't for everyone I think
that that Mighty a little sound not
everybody's into that powerful the bust
or the fart the bust the bust or the
fart this is our I look at it they're
they're both very versatile because you
can use the fart like when anyone farts
and you really don't need context for
that and with the something about the
bust I mean we've used it a lot already
same thing goes for it mhm the I think
the idea of these people on stage at a
sermon singing about something about the
bust is itself so iconic yeah I get it
just surprised
really wow well an early upset so
powerful
an an early early upset for Wendy
Williams surprising upset stomach bye
sister bye sister upset
stomach what' you
say what is
that she had a she had a a nice little
pun there you missed wait you said
something what did I miss cuz you said a
little up it was an upset and she said
it was an upset stomach for Wendy
Williams oh wow an upset stomach for
Wendy
Williams but listen I just love the Zach
G I got it I got you I was uh my focus
was over here to the next TR I'm
sorry um w wow this is this is getting
this is heating up here folks we're
almost through the first
heat okay keep spamming that uh that
11th Round Guys next up we have little
xan get out love love get out
love wait what is uh okay we have a
little error here in the document that's
okay let's so little xan actually got
into an altercation at a gas station and
and drew a gun on someone and he managed
to be so un
the
guy what the [__] you want bro get the
[__] out
out yall see this [__] right look at
little Z pulling a gun right
now look at little get out hey look at
this guy pulling the gun right now look
at this [__] heyy pull that [__]
out again homie so what struck me about
this clip is that like
to if you that you could be so
unintimidating while pointing a gun is
truly uh an achievement that only little
We call we called him affectionately
little like you at the time and I think
it
stands but we love we love little like
you we it's one of my favorite uh mo mo
like 99% of the time you hear a sound
bite on the show it's Zach but I do have
a soundboard and I that I use uh every
so often and I really only hit a few and
one of them get out that might be Dan's
favorite I love how do you have a gun
and yet be so unintimidating incredible
great get out get out anyway little then
we love him Dan so sorry to interrupt as
we
know I did too with my dad this was
abely
legendary I mean this is Bobby Lee was
in the middle of pouring his poor heart
out about the relationship with his dad
people say he had never seen him open up
like this before and as he's in the
middle of pouring his heart out Dan
interrupts him to go to
break I mean you know he was my dad was
an alcoholic and he was also violent and
used to like just my mom I mean I
remember my mom opening her mouth and
teeth being knocked out I mean he was a
nightmare and I used to
pray I didn't even believe believe in
God but I used to go God please kill me
[__] cocksuck I [__] hate him you
know hey guys I'm so sorry to interrupt
we got to go to
[Laughter]
break why would you break that
D why would you break that that was the
[__] funniest thing ever oh my God
that was so funny are you going to yeah
are you going to tell the whole story
yeah you I let
you cuz that was a 100% Ethan literally
screaming at me in all caps in our
Discord over and over again to interrupt
and saying go to break go to break you
got to go to break I was like dude this
guy is like having a moment right now
[__] up because I thought I knew it
would be funny
yeah were two there were two k I would
only ever do that to Bobby Bobby's the
only person I could ever do that to
there were there were two occasions
where we played it again this summer the
first one was with Bobby again oh yeah
oh
this and then the second one was with
logic oh and it didn't go off so oh we
did it we tried it on him to go to break
in the middle of a series and it didn't
go well did you put remember that yeah I
mean it just well I get we tried that on
logic o no it probably wasn't a good
idea just I knew cuz I know Bobby is
twisted and I knew he would find it
funny and it was I mean
here did you tell him I had nothing to
do with that I it was it's just a couple
minutes but enough to go to the bathroom
guys we'll be right back we're going to
pick this up when we come right back uh
oh I love Bobby Lee he's seriously like
one of the greatest dudes I love him wow
hey guys I'm so sorry to interrupt we
got to go you did it I didn't think you
would do it but you did it you were
screaming at me I don't think fired
actually [__] did
it you did it based on the way you
immediately laugh I just knew you it was
your fault well I wanted to be
clear oh you did it man you [__] did
it well it looks like uh this one is
very close again but um the interrupt is
edging Out Lil xan oh that's kind of an
upset because the I'm so sorry to
interrupt we got to I mean the little
xan one is so good but with the back the
the xan one was a head by then you
showed the clip and there was a huge
flip I think it's just the backstory on
that is really
something take your time and vote though
you guys be serious about this they want
the logic clip I don't know if we I
don't I think I don't have no
recollection of what you're even talking
[Music]
about yeah
okay
yeah I don't remember that I don't think
I would do that to
logic I have a vague memory but I don't
really remember I would see yeah I mean
we used it to interrupt to go to break
all the time so I could see us doing it
but I don't remember I'm having like a
negative reaction or anything but I
don't know maybe I just looked into it a
little too maybe where that I overthink
I don't know anyway Dan is winning this
and well as much as I love that little
xan I understand yeah get
out next
up we have uh chety [__] plot Chad
Hanks everybody which we talked that
greatly about last episode Chad Hanks is
uh Tom Hanks son who thinks he's from
Jamaica he's basically Al in real life
which we love about
him um oh this is tough competition here
well here it is hey guys I just want to
say that you know like now that Trump's
leaving office I think it's important to
remember that he was the president so we
should show
some [__] CL [__] them no one with B
boss man Biden [__] them R [__] CL boy
go suck
Mother where did he come from like that
came out of nut sack dude that's the
craziest thing the world has ever
produced bid that's the craziest
thing be B the chances of someone like
Chad coming out of Tom Hank nuts is like
you know how they say you know anything
like if you put a if you put a an
infinite amount of monkeys in a room
they'll eventually write a Shakespeare
play I never heard of that not an
expression someone back yeah yeah heard
that before that's the that's the chance
Chad Hanks coming out of Tom Hanks nut
this is uh probably the well I guess we
should introduce the other clip first
but so far this is the closest votes so
far okay it was actually at 5050 guys
this one bro this one wow this is from
the fire Festival
documentary um on Netflix which is great
if you haven't seen it I mean the short
story is the F you know I don't know
everyone knows about the fire Festival
right should we explain
it was a giant fraud or everyone it
everyone showed up to this not a fraud
right excuse it it was it was this giant
Festival that everyone went that was
supposed to be the biggest thing and
they showed up and basically it was like
a uh it was so poorly planned that it
was like a yeah exactly it was it was
dangerous they had to evacuate people
anyway J Ru was involved and he's on a
call trying to figure things out and
when that's when he coins this famous
line smart people on this [__] phone
call man let's think of how to dig
ourselves out of this [__] man we didn't
kill anybody nobody got hurt we made a
mistake Charles rationalizing didn't
kill anybody we were just desperate
we'll get past it I mean Grant nobody
died but we did flat out lie to the
public about what we're giving them I
mean that's
fraud like and that's not okay like as a
company
operates that's not
fraud that's not
fraud that is uh I would call that uh
false
advertising I mean it's just it's so
good wow and it works in so many ways
yeah it's not fraud that's not fraud
that's not it's uh false advertising I
would call that uh false advertising I
don't know man W those are two really
strong
contenders H what have the people
decided Well it's looking like uh Chad
has pulled ahead a little bit oh this is
an old one that's the old one uh yeah
Chad's at 55% it was actually it was a
dead heat it was at 5050 but Chad has uh
has pulled out just a little bit here
[__]
py I guess it is white boy summer after
all why why do I keep looking at the
wrong ones I don't know where did you
get the link from
Discord you guys put the new one it's in
there
back that's of course Andrew Santino
doing an impression of
chat bro you got [__] with me no
you're not [__] just look it's right
here
psych here let me pull this up here here
I just spammed it to you all right Dan
chill with
the [__] V your new nickname is
control V
[Laughter]
here this is a top meme unbelievable the
diversity residing within Tom
H truly they have different moms by the
way oh that explains a lot they have
different
moms but this literally is the spitting
and V Tom Hanks yeah and this is a
[__] chat bro just no just chat yo
this boy this homie he goes by
chat just call me
chat it's such an on though already well
so he did the white boy summer but white
boy summer might be canceled cuz the day
after he got in trouble with some
domestic abuse thing oh God right it was
a it wasn't the day after I mean well I
guess it just got brought up at the same
time white boy oh apparent all the [__]
it was like an old story I think it was
something that had previously happened
so white summer white boy summer is
officially can before it ever started
yeah [__] clut I'm so conflicted on
Chad because he is such a legend I just
wanted him to call in and oh he he
wasn't going to do that I know he was
actually threatening
uh I don't know if this is public but I
think youve talked yeah me and Andrew
Santino were were discussing him on the
podcast and he sent Andrew I don't know
why Andrew got was oh cuz he was doing
the impression yeah he he started
threatening Andrew wanting to fight him
father come forward M
award was craziest thing and he called
me fat he's like and you better tell
your fat friend to keep my name out of
his mouth too com back
family great so what what are the
results since I can't seem to find the
link you you really still can't find it
just spammed it like a thousand times
let me see at chat one we don't need to
show it 55% for there's like a million
of it's number number 12 round 12 okay
here we go guys we've found we have
located the link Against All Odds it's
not loading okay all right let's see the
results ooh close
yeah I mean I I consider this a little
bit of an upset because [__] them r j
Ru I think that I think it's just
getting a little old now I guess it
didn't and he's a hot meme right now
yeah he just so versatile and funny but
yeah I mean Chad is kind of iconic at
this moment yeah with white boy summer
and everything
happening well congratulations chat
relevant as ever I still can't believe
white boy summer it's white boy summer
and black queen summer too incidentally
let's not
com don't play that he's gonna [__]
start threatening
me Chad's gonna come for me in the DMS
all right now we're heating up all right
Vin Diesel beautiful world chisha [__]
you Dan from her first podcast
appearance which you guys couldn't find
that link
huh that was actually it was a late
edition we realized we needed a couple
more to round it out this morning and so
yeah we just didn't have what was it why
did she say [__] you do you remember why
she
said um in the
beginning I think she hated everyone all
the crew right she did it was a it was a
contentious meeting her first time on
the podcast we we were at off oh I think
Dan didn't want us to have her on that's
why oh yeah Dan you almost dered my
whole [__] my whole everything that
we have this beautiful relationship
everything that's going so great you
almost derail that you could have
dominoed my life off the rails I could
be dead right now [__] you Dan GL I'm
not dead if you didn't start a show with
Trisha I'm exaggerating okay my brother
is engaged [__] you D you dude so there
you go no but to be fair at the time was
well whatever she I hate you forever now
danc that's the
story Dan didn't want her on and you
weren't the only one by the way yeah a
lot of people were like Trisha is this
Trisha's that we don't want her have
don't give her the attention you know
[__] you Dan you weren't alone Dan this
isn't an accusation of you but so she
she she said [__] you Dan your mic do
that too it just goes up all it's like I
can't I Tien it the other day why did
they go up like that it's there's too
much tension going up you know what I
mean like there's not enough tension is
what you mean or not enough tension
maybe yeah I tighten it all down uh I
don't know well anyway um [__] you
Dan so that is the origin of that and I
mean that is really well used obviously
anytime there's any friction between
anyone and day
that always a good bed and then Vin
Diesel first one I mean come on needs no
introduction V diesel interviewed this
Brazilian reporter during the I guess
press tour for XXX and he got a little
XXX didn't he he must have been drunk or
high or something but for sure bro he
went straight up he was drunk he went
straight the [__] they get all the
celebrities uh drunk at these press
Junction drun but why would you like I
wouldn't drink if I'm on camera like
Jesus Christ oh well I've done that and
I've regretted every time cuz you're
doing it for like I used to do
it you're loosening up you think it's
going to help it never helps and well
it's I I think it's less about the
loosening up and more about it makes it
tolerable cuz they have to sit there for
12 hours and get asked the same
questions over and over and over again
so they just get hammered so here's uh
Vin Diesel talking to a Brazilian
reporter about XXX this one and he I'm
going to go guys he's so
beautiful guys he's so beautiful man am
I right or wrong look at her than you
how am I supposed to do this interview
look at this woman tell me your story
she's so beautiful go you man don't baby
so awkward tell me your story tell me
your let's get out of here let's go
let's let's go have lunch my God I love
her look how beautiful she is thank you
God wow
manks wow man yeah tell I found out that
you are a nerd like me you love Dungeons
and Dragons I'm anything like you cuz I
love
you my
God guys really look how beautiful she
is you guys think it's a joke how am I
supposed to sit over here when I'm
looking at such beauty come on guys
she's beautiful she's so beautiful I'm
in love I'm in love with the
interview so you played the I played J
so I brought you I did say did
you
so
you're so I love her man she's so
[__] sexy it's not I can't do this
interview look at
her anyone say this guys what's wrong am
I the only one that's saying look at her
what's wrong she's so [__] beautiful
it's like you can't even do an interview
with her cuz you're just
like no don't get closer right or wrong
oh my God has someone saved me when did
this turn into beautiful world when did
this turn into the most gorgeous girl in
Brazil when did this turn into I love
you you than you very much it's like uh
it's downright
horrific you know um so there it is
that's one of my favorite Clips ever
yeah cuz you think Vin Diesel you know
that's not what you imagine when you
think Vin Diesel and then you see that
and you're like oh oh come on talk to me
baby and of course Zach always uses them
at the perfect time we'll be talking
about some poor child that was falling
prey to James Charles and then Zach will
hit me with the go ahead Zack me exactly
we go Vin Diesel now is not the
time so that's tough competition because
I I hold both of those sound bites near
and dear um but uh gez it's a tough call
what do you guys think I don't see it in
the chat the link there's 5,000 votes so
people have seen it okay we usually have
more but wow okay [__] you Dan
I guess so I mean that that one is Great
Dan upet to me what yeah that's an upset
to me the Vinnie yeah there's like
there's like 10 sound bites F you Dan
yeah I agree I mean the [__] you Danos
like Dan that that one kind of hits you
hard sometimes doesn't
it hits me hard well sometimes Zach uses
it and it's like you know no I don't
really care about that you know the
thing is that bothan and Dan can get
very passionate about an argument oh
yeah and it's really funny cuz sometimes
you're wrong and sometimes then is wrong
right but like that sound bite is so
handy in those situations right it's a I
mean it can fall hard on Dan but at the
same time like like Ian pointed out I
mean play all the sound bites we have
from that Vin Diesel one Zach yeah we
just don't even really use that that
often and the Vin Diesel is St [__] you
you must be it out that when did this
turn into beautiful world what we don't
use it think it's a
joke when did this turn into I love you
talk to me baby talk to me baby the
she's so [__] beautiful you think
they talk to me baby and then the one
where it goes like it's so good the one
where he goes oh yeah or
something he goes wow wow man his voice
is so freakishly deep wow I think I
would agree with the Ian I mean this I
mean
there this is yeah like wow man he's
such a creepy
[__] and that's coming from
Zach oh god um it it it it just um I
don't know I just feel like the I just
feel like it works better I don't know
yeah I I I'm surprised but the people
have spoken let's see any change in the
vote no no it's not moving that's that's
a that's an easy win not related to the
vote yeah but umow someone sent me a
shout out from Chad Hanks to the H3
podcast really don't [__] did he do a
uh was it a cameo or some [__] yeah oh
he's on C he's he's charging big bucks
on Cameo it was like two or 3 hundred
bucks does he not remember are we going
to respect democracy or overwrite this
vote no you got to respect the vote what
El how dare you what country are
Ela I don't know this is America I can't
believe you've just said this I thought
people do whatever is ready to
overtake to overthrow the
government and it's still a
mocka just so you understand this
election was a fraud he was gone this
election of it's a fraud something
happened there in the vote yeah we got a
shout out from
Chad Cheta oh my God this is
exciting man of the hour
hey man it's Chad Hanks shout out to H3
podcast and all the foot soldiers I know
y'all uh um has been supporting me I
appreciate it oh thank you guys peace oh
bro
you you could have put more effort into
that check how busy are you wait hold on
let's appreciate what we got how much
that can someone look up how much a
cameo cost from chat I feel
like yes it was that was a cameo wasn't
it why are you saying that oh I I
thought that's what AB said we're just
assuming I mean it was assumption before
we watched it but that didn't seem like
a cameo me who 300 299 300 bucks wait
who whoa who is this a cameo or is this
a free video cuz that changes a
lot what's the comment
say h i mean it's got to be a cameo yeah
why I mean probably but does a cameo
have a cameo thing it does but it looks
like it's cro been cropped a little bit
so it may have been cropped out I don't
know we have to get to the bottom of
this cuz if it's not a cameo then we
love Chad if it is a cameo then I feel
like the person got ripped off for $300
but he could have refused it if
he I don't think he knows anything they
were just like yo we're foot soldiers we
support you and he was just reading the
script cuz I bought a bunch of cameos
from celebs yeah dude he's just totally
reading hey man it's Chad Hanks shout
out to H3 podcast and all the foot
soldiers I know y'all uh um has been
supporting me I appreciate it thank you
guys peace that's totally a cameo yeah
come on what the [__] is that that's
duck that was like 10 seconds yeah dude
what is it like uh what is it Skippy
Skippy does cameos they're like 30
minutes long yeah he charges a heck of a
lot less yeah Cameo is public someone is
saying so we could check if it's there
oh you know what they did recently you
have to become a member of his to watch
his other cameos you have to pay a
monthly Fe now if you want to watch his
other cameos isn't that amazing all I
could be wrong maybe I misinterpreted
yes no it's it's I don't know how other
users are but his specifically is free
to join his members version oh it's free
it's yeah it's free to join why would I
pay to watch him do came for other
people that's so bizarre H although to
be fair it was always seems so bizarre
to me that you could watch other cameos
that he did yeah it's so weird like why
but why would you pay to watch it I mean
that's just [__] bizarre that's
always been an option when you buy The
Cameo to public it or not yeah oh it's
up to the person buying it if they want
well shout out to the
island Chet CH okay so where are we uh
Vin Diesel has lost to Trisha [__] you
Dan quite an upset I have to
say I don't agree with that one I'm
sorry d z is taking his El is ready to
overthrow democracy as we know
it I don't know maybe we get like one
over a huge one override as the part of
the rules like we get like one Vito that
we can you have a v you can cast a vote
Ela this is a democracy right yo I
expected Vin to be a deep rounder man I
gotta say my only response to that is
wow
man all right well we're coming close to
the first
bracket how is it any 's voice that
deep cigarettes and alcohol right he
does smoke I've seen those Paparazzi
Clips love
him all right e the pooo vers um let's
see let's see e the pooo legendary sh
this is bro everyone my name is Pastor
Dr Martin guy in Uganda who hates gay
people he [__] hates him so much
right that he pretty much spends every
waking hour uh
researching gay porn similar to the gay
Milkman as we like to call him G is
another type of milk this guy took it
way further though like holy smoke in
the capacity as the chairman milk the
national task force against
homosexuality in Uganda National we are
making legislation to make sure that
Sodom and homosexual it never sees the
light of legality in this land of the
par of Africa I've taken time to do a
little research to know what homosexuals
do in the privacy of their bedroom one
of the thing they do is called anol
leing where a man's iners is elck like
this by the other person I like ice
cream and then what even poo comes out
the other poo is out bro this guy's on
the Weir part of the internet
like I don't think that's normal yeah if
the PO Comes This is sick I mean if
you're watching like scat porn which is
pretty weird I didn't you can I don't
think you can even find that on PornHub
it's a leaked like you have to search
like very deep and hard to find eating
the poo poo porn and then they eat the
poo poo they other they do is they have
a sex practice people are taking notes
by the way they got a notebook out
people are taking notes you leaked like
what's that domain what's the
URL awesome have a sex practice called
fisting where they insert their hand
into the other man's hand and it goes
all into the eners all the way and it is
so painful they have to take drugs but
they enjoy
it this guy so much for me I'm just
going to let it play cuz I I can't I
can't comment on that now if we have any
children please step out this is a
parental guidance moment that child can
do there's 10 people in the room you can
see if this children or
not moved out so I've done
research this is what they do number one
you can see a man here having sucked the
other person's rectum and the other
person is pooing and this one is eating
the Poo I mean yeah you found a one
really weird video yeah you should see
heterosexual people do
man oh boy if you think that's crazy
have you seen two girls one cup oh that
is gay I guess
too I guess everyone eats the poop it's
not
uh SC eating the poop is
nothing has nothing to do with sexual
orientation all over the place the tell
when you have a law against
homosexuality do you say except eating
po hey I mean look at this guy sincerely
Bishop a Coman I know why does everyone
need to see it he's like doing a bit
totally it's crazy man it's
awesome we do not want this sickness
this is sick and it's therefore deviant
we do not want it now they start off by
touching each other's genitals and
smelling each other then keep forcing
everyone to watch it it's crazy I love
that I love that he's making everyone
watch this you know he's got folders and
folders and folders of the [__] on me as
the poop all over the other person's
face as if that is not enough he puts
the hand deeper as Africans we want to
ask Barack Obama to explain to us is
this what he wants to bring to Africa as
a human right to eat the poooo of our
children
the human right to eat the poooo ladies
and gentlemen Barack Obama wants to
bring the human right to eat the poop so
that's a tough one yeah it's a really
tough
one the next one is a Joe Biden who we
love Joe Biden no one has ever said
it oh he gets is this when he says Pony
face dog faed pony soldier or I don't
know if it's part of the calls him fat I
don't it is well let's see Joe's about
the it was all like in the same week
yeah Joe had bad week
by say you were doing anything wrong you
said I set up my son to work in an oil
company is that what you said get your
word straight Jack that's
I MSNBC you don't hear that in MSNBC you
did not hear that you heard look okay
I'm not going to get an argument you man
I don't well yeah you do but uh but look
fat look he said look fat yeah man it's
so czyy it's called the dude fat look
fat look fat who that meet me outside I
love that look fat look here's a deal a
deal I never heard anyone like use the
word like that before as like a pron get
your work straight Jack that's
awesome okay I'm a little conf confused
by what okay going on right now my
screen is blocked in and what you want
to do well look at my
screen okay we're
back I have to figure that
out next
up this is um wait we didn't look at the
results yeah sorry getting ahead of
myself all right what do we got we've
got
UMO is uh is winning in a blowout 7 73%
when I saw the Joe B I was like come on
how do how do you eat the poooo how do
you beat that eat the Poo's pretty good
Joe Biden okay we're coming down
ooh this is the one we've all been
waiting for again this could be a final
round
one we've got w-e P wake
up wake up Mobility Mary oh that's
brutal you know what it's old though so
we'll see how people respond so this is
Wally P uh he's an underground Tik
tocker let's say uh who who well I don't
I don't think words can describe him
other than just still kind like the top
Tik to wake up
911 today same day happened
2001 it's just funny and it works I
don't know why but it always works like
Zach hit it just hit us with like a 911
Jo bid you know what I mean 911 like
just works everywhere I think if I this
might be my favorite song but all it's
up there for me too I'm big fan Mobility
Mary now this was a old meme some privy
to uh Mobility Mary was this uh well she
had a that's why we have the Gatsby
she's a
Mobility
um she had a YouTube channel where she
would basically cruise around their
Santa Monica LA and film her encounters
with people on her mobility scooter and
um well she was convinced the world was
kind of like just getting in her way but
like the truth was was far from that I
mean seems like more more that she was
the issue and here's one example of
her following someone into a Taco Bell
she's riding in the middle of the road
in her mobility
scooter and she's following someone into
a t Bell who she perceived to have tried
to run her off the
road oh my
God didn't really seem
close I think he used the road um
correctly no I I mean yeah she's not
supposed to be
there that problem with that Runner yeah
so she follows this guy down into the
Taco Bell drive-thru to give him give
him some peace of mind and there and
this by the way is
just excuse me sir excuse me
sir
sir you almost hit me you made a totally
illegal move the [__] away from
me yes I'm serious there's no [__]
almost in life I did not hit you I said
you almost hit me you made an ille get
the [__] off the street with that thing
on the street it's not a car well anyway
um well anyway
there's lots and lots of these videos of
Mobility Mary and so we love her
disability Mobility there's so many
great soundbites but there it's a bit
it's been around I mean it's been a
while go ahead and play some of the
classics if you would please Zach oh my
God great well better it hits me than
hits you
excellent I need to get out of the
street any go away you get the idea but
the results are in and it is a clear win
for wake up wake up I think he's just
more relevant to 911 what's happening be
247 every
day bad boy bad boy what you gonna do
Ian he he's kind of he is in a way the
new Mobility man yeah this message from
Muhammad love him we've been trying to
get in touch with him for a while any
any progress on that Zach
nothing we uh ab ab found some very good
information I mean he's a big deal you
guys are tracking him down yeah he's got
a whole underground he's got a a little
bit of um cult Cult of Personality built
around him there's there's some Discord
server that that of just people that
like really diligently follow his every
uh his Every Move online well we have
his phone number we know it's his phone
number number he call the right yeah he
just doesn't answer he'll FaceTime you
like there's evidence of him just like
face some other people have pointed face
he must have another phone that he uses
privately yeah maybe yeah I found his
address too okay Cal Down Easy that you
don't need to
tell Z come
on got his blood
type I I when I go deep I go deep okay
all right I didn't ask for that just for
the record I didn't ask Zach to find his
address I just wanted to try to get him
on the
show now Zach's now he needs a
restraining order one my crew
mates
Jesus AB do you want to tell them your
idea maybe not after
that is it the go
to go ahead I don't remember
honestly okay no tell him go I we were
gonna we were gonna take a road trip oh
yeah in in search of him
yeah let's not do
that I definitely don't condone you guys
going to the dress that you found in
search of well 911 the creator of the
Discord said that he's pretty sure that
he knows about the show oh he's familiar
really what hey
hey what's up what's up what's up W if
you're watching we're I want to talk to
so bad huge fans of Wally I am wake I'm
woken
up well we're down to the last round of
our heat all right first round we've got
Kenneth copelan geezus is your Source I
don't have a I don't have a click for
that Jesus is your well you guys know
Kenneth copel I've talked about him
psychotic uh mul millionaire Jesus he's
the guy who famously said he had to buy
a private plane because he didn't want
to travel and a tube with a bunch of
demons
yeah relatable Rel relatable for
sure go ahead play uh your your fa your
best Kenneth if you would for me please
Z Jesus is your source source oh Jesus
oh oh Jesus a lot of those I'm Healed in
the name of
Jesus and um Yoko Ono
wife of beloved uh artist John Lennon
from rest in peace she has taken up the
mantle after his death uh musically in
fact she created an
album oh this is from this is her
message to Donald Trump I thought this
was from her album war zone This Is War
yeah she's got a distinct
Style
everybody leaves
behind is talented wife Joo who to
reinterpret his music for the
world do you have war zone yeah hit me
with a war zone she also put on an album
recently a few years ago called war zone
which uh Rivals maybe some of her
husband's I mean it certainly Rivals
um Paul
yeah Paul I mean easily Paul McCartney
John lenon it's better than Wings man
anything George ever you have a sound I
don't I just have the one we played
because I think war zone I
think war zone well of course it
did well I mean a talent for the for the
AES I'm certain by the way if she wasn't
the ex-wife of John Lennard that uh the
world would be captivated by her
stunning and daring
art
results oo now this is I think we're
going to have to wait for more
votes it's currently Copeland is barely
in the lead barely close close I'm
surprised by that I mean yeah I mean
this one's a CO TOS for me
yeah
all right think we're going to give it
to Kenneth I'm sorry
Yoko I'm so sorry well congratulations
to all of our first round winners now
what do we do J now things get really
heated up this one's going to go close
uh much faster now that we got the
background um so we're going to go
up so round two let's just play them
discuss and vote we have Jared Leto
Joker Laugh versus Trisha [__] you AB go
ahead Jared Leto
everybody uh Academy Award winner if I'm
not wrong
right right right right right right Z
[__] you
AB [__] you wait Can I please just
acknowledge that Trisha [__] you Dan and
[__]
it's kind of the same thing but are we
going to end up with a Trisha versus
Trisha like Showdown I I may defend my
sound bite she puts a lot more emphasize
emphasis on the [__] in mind that's true
that's that's [__]
right okay well and then hit me hit me
with the um the Joker
please Jared Leto Academy Award
winner
no Trisha oh I foresee trouble in the
lab with with we you know what we should
have done I got to say the Tre the two
of them should be one we should have put
them together against each other early
bracket cuz like everyone else is like
one is a package you know but it's too
late it's just going to end up being
Trisha versus Trisha I'm
afraid well there it is clear
winner Jared Leto won the Academy War
but he did not win n the soundbite
competition tough luck this next one is
it going to be interesting for sure
shout out to the family versus Trump
okay shout out to his
[Music]
family this one is inter
okay got the big Trump okay versus the
shout out to his family okay man that's
a tough one shout out to his
[Music]
family his family do we crash the site
again maybe I'm seeing Zero votes ladies
and genten it it was only posted we're
moving so fast that you got to give it a
okay so the Trump one what do you what
are you feeling on this one Ela as we
wait for you want me to say my vote yeah
go ahead I think David guda shout out to
the family yeah
that true shout out to his I can't get
enough of it when yeah and it it made me
laugh so much but when I watch the Trump
clip I did give me a greater
appreciation but the shout out to his
family makes me laugh so much I am not
seeing any votes do I have the right
link I think yeah I think it's not
working it let me vote but um oh here we
go we have 100% what it's just not
working it's it's bugging out just give
it a second think we know who's going to
win this one though right you know we
might we might be seeing a a favorite
maybe to win the whole thing here
in actually now that I think about it I
think we see maybe our first favorite to
win here we go there go oh yeah shout
out to his family the clear winner maybe
a favorite to win the his family this is
exciting shout out to his family has
anyone ever shouted out his family
David's family yeah oh that's a good
point well let me be the
first okay that's a that's a big win I
think we have our early
favorite all
wow James Charles oh no yeah first
quarter oh
no that's tough I just my basement go
ahead with the I just peed in my
basement I just peed in my basement now
the thing about the quartering is that
like most people don't know who he is
our audience knows who I mean we did a
about him and stle keeps crashing yeah I
just peed in my basement you guys are
you guys are pinning it right you don't
need to spam it do you Dan they do it
all trying to get it all over the place
I know
it that's a tough decision I oh no I
think I know what what what I would vote
for this guy
yeah for me I think I'm not going to
vote cuz I don't want to muddy the water
wait this is the old one oh
no but I know I think I would vote for
frankly oh no but I'm not voting my God
I just peed in my Bas difference I can't
see the results I see no yeah
yep wow maybe another favorite oh no
we're seeing to win the whole
competition now we're getting really
down to it what did they say separating
the chaff from the chuff what's that the
wheat from the chaff right yep we're
separating the wheat this is a little
spooked M spook mot
spooko moving light right along okay
this is a tough one this could go either
way Ace family
stop
stop wow I love that sound it makes me
so happy
and Carlos but Carlos bit connect that's
go
ahead be
[Music]
connect
W
man that's a tough call I'm so
excited who would I vote for people
saying the Link's broken are we having
trouble with straw pull again
whoa h
oh Dan pinned days a week love justn
snarked on you
Dan thank you oh he said it was his
fault oh okay I'm not I not sigic bla
can you just not read our private chat
out on the show constantly stop oh yeah
I already asked you not to do that I
asked you not to do that I told you guys
I told you guys if it's here I'm going
to [__] read it if y'all want to chat
behind the scenes No
mm what should I not read that you
should
not okay especially when you
misunderstand it well then when am I how
am I supposed to know when to read it
and when not to read it it's just it's a
priv it's obvious the context is not
something meant to be read
out we all
have all right guys we have a really
close one now this is wow this is a
quarter are we in the quarterfinals what
would you call this wow
man it's looking like the stop is edging
it out so
close CL oh my god wow this is our
closest vote
yet oh nope I think Ace just locked it
up 53% stop yeah it's it's going up
47% Carlos man stop is gold I mean I get
it bigon next grade but stop wait play
the sound the one in the distance
sa yeah stop deserves it stop deserves
it okay wow this is good oh wait got
we've been streaming for 3 hours yeah
we're going to well here look we're here
for the long one
who
stop we got to see this through just
like the James Charles video I just I
love you there's like two different
clips of it yeah dude the fact the best
the fact that somebody somebody went
back and listened to that video and
spotted it faintly in the background and
they I think it was on the subreddit and
I and that was just like such a powerful
moment
yeah
such so good
well all right what's next next up we
have Will Smith um rewind time or
something's about to bus now it's rewind
time those were both blowouts in their
previous rounds so I feel like this one
to be I'm a strong favor I I'm I'm a
strong
favor on one of these but I will wait
for the
results go ahead the Christians are
ready for God's uh
the
off ooh
whoa this is a shocking
upset let's give it a little bit more
time it's not it's not many votes yet
but this is neck and neck this is
aill this is unbelievable the something
is about the bus is currently in the
lead the Busters have it over the world
famous ah
fornight Will Smith I thought Will Smith
would win this one for sure wait what's
going on oh that's what I was saying it
wasn't that many votes yet you gota yeah
it didn't it didn't actually change it
was
just okay something about to bus is a
has a strong passionate I agree with
that
vote it's just I think Will Smith is
maybe kind of like don't you say
it okay no I'm kidding played out old
it's a little old
yeah it's been a while oh my
goodness that was great I didn't hear
Zach played again how he don't want me
man that's
perfect wow but this is just this is
really a strong show for something about
the something about the bust is
fantastic I know it's recent well
something has busted yeah and so we
congratulate something is about to bust
is about to
bust
okay
fantastic Here We Go Round 22 we are
coming to the end of this there's not
that many rounds left folks we are
coming right into the end of this WOW
Dan interrupting Bobby Lee how dare you
Dan have you no heart hey guys I'm so
sorry to interrupt we got to go to break
Bobby League tearing his heart out he
has never been this emotional
before and Dan dares to interrupt him to
go to break unbel hey guys I'm so sorry
to interrupt we got to go to break but
coming in is the white boy himself white
boy summer [__] clot hit him with it
psych psych hit him with all of his the
best CH [__] CL yeah [__] them R [__]
CL boy go suck
mother all right straw p with boss man
there's so many great chat
moments back that one is Andrew Santino
not to be confused with Chad
Hanks I I constantly wonder what do you
think
um Tom Hanks thinks about his son Chad
like what did they talk
about what did they talk about um should
have had a visectomy
bisectomy Zach
says um well I gotta say the early vote
is in and it's looking like got to go to
break oh wow which kind of surpris I was
expecting a chat Victory frankly yeah
because I thought that one is
old but I think the lore so sorry to
interrupt we got to go to break the lore
the moment yeah of the Bobby
Le but it's coming back for Chad I'm
actually so sorry to interrupt we got to
go to
break and that's looking like a wow I
expected chat cool really
did
okay um cup next okay this one I bro
please I can't have Trisha coming in on
both sides of this bracket well let's
see what
happens okay I mean eat the poop was a
strong competitor you got [__] you Dan
you got [__] you Dan vers eat the poooo
this is a big battle this battle could
determine the rest of this entire
tournament
I can I urge you all to consider this
not lightly to consider
it cast your vote with as much uh uh
meditation and thought as James Charles
has put into his crimes since yesterday
morning one morph called
him okay this is close
one oh
brother please don't be a blowout I'm be
so sad if this is just a blow out wow
man I love Trisha I just I can't have a
Trisha versus Trisha this is just seems
like vote manipulation
Ethan stop the count all right yeah stop
the count we need to [__] you Ian we
should get we should get Trisha to say
[__] you to to each crew member
including me just to be fair so that we
can bust it out it was just the whole
show would just be Trisha cursing all us
out look what kind I do
Ian Trisha's winning I mean I knew this
would then that's the that's the nature
of the Beast what can I do I'm not
trying to overthrow democracy it's a
good no it's a good sound bite I can't
like disagree with the vote I love this
sound bite I just feel like we made a
technical mistake here by putting two of
them they should have gone head to head
at the beginning no they should have
been together group I agree with you
there should have just been one because
that's what we did with everyone else oh
no
but we can't change it now she's going
to win the whole [__] thing we can't
change it now how can we change it the
bracket are sent you're making and
you're I feel like you're actually
making it worse by talking like this
because everyone's going to vote against
me yeah I know
exactly all right let's continue
everybody come on this is guys stop
we've been we've gone too far into this
I think that there's listen it's a great
sound bite [__] you Dan like so it's
like it's not like rigged you know what
I mean so let's just see what happens
yeah Trisha congratulations you have two
spots in these
semifinals all right quarterfinals right
quarterfinals yeah or no wait I guess
the semi is the next round isn't it okay
next up so congratulations [__] you
Dan is a wake up Joe
Biden hit him with the walles wake
up with the w and then hit him with the
Copelands
thank you Zach Jesus is your
Source oh
Jesus this is so
stupid oh Jesus I'm Healed in the name
of Jesus so that of course is Kenneth
copelan head of copelan Ministries it's
kind of funny his name's copelan because
that's like the meme about like uh
copium what is that like when all the
Maga people were like crying about Trump
losing there was a meme of like the PE
the paye Frog am I saying it right nope
[__]
peee that's good oh that's a fresh
one um anyway he he's you know cope it
is to like cope with something so he's
taking copium got like a face mask got
it so a little bit of a inside me there
had it oh Wally smashed it
out Wally deserves it all yeah I had oh
thank you uh AB for everybody who
doesn't know now this we've turned into
a Know Your Meme show cop thank you very
much when you need to cope with
something uh there you have
it thank you thank you with peace and
love wow this is the biggest uh blowout
we've had actually this round I mean
Wally Wally's might pick for for the
final really you think Wally's going to
make okay well no one of one listen it
it's not it's I'm not making the
prediction that it's going to wi I'm
saying that is my favorite yeah well
let's guys
we we are down to four brackets all
right this is heating up wow
man let's go to the first uh so what do
we call we got the
quarter semifinals the quarterfinals
what the [__] you call this
recet oh this is so it's round three
whatever whatever that means okay we've
got here now
[__] you AB [__] you
AB such a good [__] and David GAA dude
this is it shout out to his family this
is the true test of Trisha's power here
because shout out to the family I think
is a favorite to win the whole thing I
think so too so if Trisha can overcome
David Guta and shouting out to George
Floyd's
family okay you know what I think the
truth is um going to
shout out to his family
look dude come on you all know thank you
that's the right choice thank you shout
out to his family you guys know shout
out to his that's the funniest thing
ever okay good good good there's still I
I was just I was afraid I was a little
bit afraid no I see your point you were
afraid that it's just like blindly
voting for TR no just like for for the
meme too and I mean look it is good
they're great sound bites I'm not saying
but shout out to his
family congratulations Dave guda what's
is he made a song that I would know did
he make the d d do song no definitely
not
no um I'm sure he he has some hits that
you probably would recognize really I
don't really listen to that type of
music yeah but it's always like in
stores and oh really it's like H&M music
probably yeah sounds right yeah I mean
he's like big yeah big room like medium
guy well
wow I think we have to pause for a sec
because uh straw P's not working
ohw at a time like this oh no right it
works for
me well I'm unable to make a new one I'm
working
on oh well that this is exciting now now
we are really getting wow dude we're
going to end up with such a crazy match
up next because we have shout out to the
family versus either o no or stop oh and
this is really it's really really up
well oh no vers stop is a even a super
hard match up
there mhm hit me with the stop sack and
then hit me with the far distance uh uh
stop if you would please stop m
yeah you hear that in the
background it looks like we got it yeah
okay we're up we're up and running guys
yeah round round
26 to me the even funnier one is the one
in the background play that a few
times okay but James Charles you know
him man this might be the only thing we
have left of him after uh what sounded
like the FBI ra oh no right
it's a tough
competition man but I I
think I have a feeling I I personally I
think I voted I think I'm going with the
I think I I would vote with stop on in
this case um as my personal preference
just because of the perspective and the
story yeah me the James Charles one is
prolific though we do use that one a
lot just remember whoever wins this is
going up against shout out to the f
family which is right which is going to
be a hell of a
showdown it's the big
show this is wild tell you what uh
strule is currently failing us thank you
stle yeah I've never really seen it act
so shitty just a bad day for it we
spamming oh wow that close all right
everyone vote cuz this is so close yeah
vote now this is important yeah your
vote your vote matters every vote counts
get out to the polls wait in lines don't
let anyone turn you
away your vote
matters oh no what is that there's like
a when you play the oh no it's like a
sound effect from a video oh
no oh no well with 6,000 votes
cast it looks like uh with 52% stop I
think the ace family is taking it home I
think the lore behind that story is just
really too oh there's a little bit of
update 7,000
votes thank you for participating in
democracy everybody uh democracy only
works when you participate so thank you
shout out to the
[Music]
families okay this is the matchup wow
the Winner's going to the finals okay
let's go down to the lower bracket here
okay
um something is about to bust which
seems to be about to bust a crowd
favorite
mhm a little bit of
a something about the bus which has been
winning uh handedly throughout the
entire tournament a little bit of a Dark
Horse taking it it is a bit of a Dark
Horse taking man I feel like a real
Sports anal this is what they do all day
nothing actually happens with time Healy
time a little bit of a Dark Horse coming
in uh something as about to bus we've
had our eyes on him the whole Tournament
winning handedly of coming in a favorite
here at the end of the tournament versus
so sorry to interrupt Dan Bob breing in
on Bobby Lee uh uh Bobby Lee interrupted
hey guys I'm so sorry to interrupt we
got to go to break Dan rudely
interrupting Bobby Lee as he was gushing
his heart out Dan
everybody hey guys I'm so sorry inter
Fair news here everyone make sure you
vote
so let me open some things about the Bus
Let's watch both of these clips back
because I feel that and finally new rule
if we're going to have a new roaring why
the [__] is Bill finally new rule if
we're going to have a new so
odd um let's watch both of these clips
as the voting takes place because they
both in the source are incredibly good
incredibly powerful looks like there's
already a I got to tell you that this
isn't even it's not close my
goodness wow ladies and gentlemen it
looks like the clips aren't necessary at
this point the dark horse is in the lead
here uh surprising everybody something
about to bust the Christians coming here
taking the lead with 62% handily
defeating so sorry to interrupt now
what's interesting about this
one is that so sorry to interrupt has
been sweeping it so far but the Dark
Horse blowout every round previous but
it just couldn't it didn't have what it
took to the Christian singers did not
expect something about the bus to take
it this far in the tournament folks but
uh here we are and wow they really
surprised us they are going to the
quarterfinals they are
officially uh wow wow okay or I guess
the semifinal now th oh wow this is a
true test for Trisha once again
Trisha [__] you Dan legendary sound bite
one of Zach's
favorites one of Zach's favorite sound
bites versus our boy our Dan's favorite
yeah one of our favorites I think
somebody else said it was his favorite
too was it that or it's you definitely
one of my favorites Wall-E is just such
a force to be reckon with coming into
this a definite favorite uh wake up I
feel like Trisha winning at this point
would be an
upset but uh here we go the tournament
on the Voting is in uh the votes are
coming in right now I got to tell you
folks I'm trying I'm trying to be an
announcer trying to keep it entertaining
Joe Biden coming in with the Joe Biden
coming in here hot at 911 go ahead Wally
with Joe Biden wake up and and if you
can hit me with a 911 please Zach thank
you so much 911 911 wake up wake up 911
okay and Trisha wake up wake up here we
go the results are not in not in make
sure you vote now people just want to
give a shout out to our sponsor do we
have uh shout out to our sponsor uh Chad
Hanks patreon folks shout out to Chad
Hanks patreon [__] you Dan $300 for 7c
video thank you to Chad Hanks welcome to
Chad Hanks Studio folks all right votes
are coming in votes are coming in for o
okay so we only have one that's glitched
out yeah yeah yeah the amount of votes
coming in for man is overwhelming here
the
early okay oh okay we've had an update a
lot of activity we have 7,000 votes
currently this is a lot of activity more
than we've seen on previous votes a lot
of passion
here wow
man wow Trisha's [__] you Dan in the
early lead against WALL-E who was the
favorite coming into this tournament
what the [__] wow wow wow Zach is
visably upset Zach would you like to say
anything that's I mean that's I some B
weak I'm sorry no no no you know no
whack against tra I love her but like
like what they're just doing it to troll
Ethan at this point he went too hard you
think so hold on hold on hold on got
skewed no I don't think yeah on the
other one the vote this is real worked I
agree because shout out to the family
destroyed Trisha yeah that's true that's
true this is real [__] and it's really
close um now you I think you may have
gotten too close to Wally with piing out
his address planing this whole [__]
doyer about trying to find it this is a
this is we're get more
votes go all the way yeah I mean this is
how do how how do you how does that lose
what
like this is the greatest [__] the
internet has ever seen I kind of feel
like he's a cast member at this point
yeah yeah Wally's near and dear our I
mean I voted for Wall-E I'm with you but
what can you do we we did a segment
where we all tried to recreate Wall-E
sound bites I don't remember the [__]
you Dan segment yeah I think there need
to be some ex cast is taking this very
hard L there needs to be some executive
order we're all
B wait we have talk of mutiny here today
in the studio executive ORD how many
votes it's getting the quantity of votes
coming in 9,000 this is a
record-breaking turnout it's a Sixpoint
spread though I don't I don't think it's
wow we're going to call it got it this
is one of the biggest upsets upset
stomach over here we have 9,000 votes
cast this is democracy in action people
democracy suck I'm not accepting this
this this this election is a fraud I'm
sorry they're stealing it
steing I think I think there needs to be
some executive order I'm not even joking
so so that's not happening so how do you
for see executive order working right
now Zach sign sign the petition Wally
it's so classic I mean how does that
[__] how does that
lose I'm mad about it I like that do you
want to hold a Riley kind do
yeah so do we make another poll if we
should do an executive have action for
Wally to win no you can't you can't I'm
kidding recount people Zach the
people recount that [__] man we got AA
stle I mean what's the recount it's
digital I don't know they got fake
machines in Georgia I don't know drop PO
is like a Dominion 10,000 votes I'm I'm
[__] pissed I'm sorry the sound L we
I feel like I I I I okay he can't talk
Zack is
rered zck had money on this or something
Z speechless
speechless I don't know I honestly I'm
shocked I've never seen Zach this
visibly be upset over the upset of
Wall's loss to Trisha 10,000 almost
10,000 votes cast 9
indeed what would you describe your
feeling feelings as of today Zack if you
could play sound bite to express it I
heartbroken yeah I was trying to te you
up there for
911 you can't even think I know I'm
stunned I'm
[__] yeah well could cry yeah Ian I
mean uh it seems just in general
everybody seems this is a really
hard-fought battle I mean I haven't seen
tensions like this since the election of
2020 frankly MH
I mean Zach is the he's the music maker
this is his instrument you know so of
course he has a little passion about
this this is his language
definitely true like it's okay I I oh go
ahead
please Ethan and Ela as coming from a
patron of the H3 podcast please the
Supreme Court you guys you're still
trying to appeal to
over get the [__] out of here I already
tried it earlier yeah I mean Ela even my
wife and co-host tried to overthrow a
result uh but I like I just I like to
witness the the passion me gravel Zach
it's it's clear that you're passionate
about Wall-E and I love that about you
listen I'm disappointed too but when
when these things happen you just got to
pick up the pieces and you got to closer
yeah you got to look to the Future you
got we need people are still voting and
it's not getting you know what we need
to do Zach we need a Grassroots movement
going to the next election we need to go
door to door we need to canvas we need
to get the word out right but that [__]
takes you just got to work twice as hard
next time I just I'm hurt like I'm I to
feel pain in my heart all right Zach
thank you for your input uh time to move
on it is a stunning upset Trisha [__]
you Dan moving up I want freedom from
the
world okay guys all right now we have
come down down to the sem here we go
this is coming down to a nailbiter folks
this first round
is
unpredictable shout out to the family
David
gues David Gucci David guci David Gucci
David shout out to his
family uh versus of course the infamous
Ace family stop already know my
vote The Quiet One Lead With The Quiet
One you got him okay I mean listen this
one's easy it's easy for you go you can
you can tell what you would vote no I'll
wait you'll wait it's not easy for me
but I think I know who who I prefer
to it's not
easy it seems like it wasn't a hard
decision for the audience stop shout out
to the family coming in and is actually
in the
semis to get a blowout in the semis like
that that's ladies and gentlemen we are
seeing a blowout today shout out to his
family taking a commanding lead over
stop in the semifinals we didn't expect
to see such a blowout here folks but wow
wow we've been saying shout out to the
familyes a favorite to win once it
overcame Trisha in the last round we
knew it was a stunning competitor and
here we are seeing evidence of that
shout out to his family David
wake up Wall-E is out Wally is out
tournament though you can't silence
him Wally is out Ace family is
out bye-bye shout out to the family
advances to the
finals shout out next
one that one's going to be a tough
competitor that's going to be hard to
beat I don't know what what to expect
from the people's vote dude there's like
a huge passion for some things about to
bust I mean I like that one but like
people are crazy passionate about
it it is so we've got something is about
folks welcome here today to the final
game of the semif finals up against
something is about to bust something is
about to bust of course talking about
the Lord spraying down his jiz on his
followers we love that shout out to
Kenneth copelan Ministries for that one
something's about to bust up against
the wow stunning competitor [__] you Dan
go ahead and play it Zach I know you
don't want to but we need Fu Dan thank
you [__] you Dan breaks his heart to
play it but he soldiers through like
like the soldier we know he is [__] you
Dan [__] you Dan a bit of a Dark Horse
coming in strong but defeating handily
every round here up and leading up to
this moment so this is a true challenge
for [__] you Dan coming at it from some
something is about to bust a fan
favorite
unpredictable we don't know which way
this is going folks this is the
semifinals the last one the winner
advance to the finals what do we
have
who this is the
closest we have ever seen holy [__] it
was 5050 people get your votes in this
is
remarkable this is a stunningly close
battle this is the final round before
the end we're seeing a 51% [__] you down
to a 49% something is 5050 I'm losing my
mind I can't believe what I'm saying
we're at a dead heat in 5050 [__] you
Dan for something is about to bus this
is a true competition flip back [__] you
Dan 51% 52% [__] you Dan [__] you Dan
taking a commanding lead this is
unbelievable what I'm seeing [__] you
Dan taking a commanding lead over
something is about to bust Sher what's
your vote we have 8000 th000 votes and
oh [__] you Dan takes a sharper lead
against something is about to
bust oh my
goodness wow that was
incredible whoa [__] you Dan we got we
have a new update a new batch of vote a
dump As Trump would say we just got a
dump massive dump we just got a massive
dump of votes we're at back to 50 a
massive dump they call him
dump [__] you oh no another dump this is
so close you guys I can't believe this I
can't watch [__] took another lead
Alfredo your vote big massive dumps
52% [__] you Dan holds the lead against
something is about to bust folks I am
blown away by the closest of the
semifinal Showdown the winner advance to
the finals to go against shout out to
the family almost 10 know was you Fredo
Zach oh
Fredo I know it was you
Fredo Shredder you want to come up where
are you let's let it even out here a
little bit cuz make sure we don't have
any more dumps Shredder come here wow
that was exciting you guys they call
them dumps wow well I can't say I'm
surprised [__] you Dan has shown to be
just unbelievable fortitude I mean if it
can beat
Wall-E yeah it can beat any and I feel
like we have a
true
unpredictable
thrilling final [__] you Dan for shout
out to the
family this is you call it yeah it's
called okay Trisha won by at this point
you know four four points
so
wow this is the
matchup wow I got to say I mean this is
a really strong final showing shout out
to the family can we get some tense
music oh thank
you shout out to the
family first [__] you
Dan this can go either
way both beloved both winning with
stunning decisiveness throughout the
entire competition [__] you Dan [__] you
Dan oh my God was said to Trisha in the
first
episode yet Dave gooda chees on the the
night after George Floyd's uh a
murder shout out to his family shouted
out his family in a set and then
jovially pumped along afterwards okay
make sure you click the correct one it
says final round cuz I clicked the old
one and I was like oh round 3 shout out
to his family I I I cannot I'm click
this is such a I this is such a coin
toss it could go any
way I am I'm on the edge of my seats
this is the final folks if you are
watching Everybody Get Your vote in [__]
you Dan I'm clicking the results I'm
clicking the results now I mean oh I
need more music I lost the music oh no
straw full crashed oh no this is too
much I want everybody voting now this is
too important okay we have some data
coming in here
from the first precinct need that that
drama the drama music we got it Dave G
shout out to the family we got it one
dump from
guda [__] you 3500 votes we don't yet
have data on [__] you Dan but we're
waiting for the first dump
here this is nail
biting they call them dumps they call
them dumps we're waiting for big massive
[Laughter]
dump [__] you Dan we're waiting on the
data here folks we've got so far
3,419 see a lot of people saying it's
not working it's I think I think we're
killing come on straw remember guys de I
just got a I just got a 5503 ER just
everyone be patient democracy only works
when you wait in line stay in line your
vote matters it's crashed your vote
matters it's like fully crashed we love
you you're very special
stay in mind people use straw pull for
this kind of [__] all the time it's
never an issue I think I don't know that
they're ready to have like 50 or mean I
don't know 20,000 people no I see big
streamers use straw all the time for
this kind of stuff it's never really a
problem I think they're just look at me
I had a beat off just getting
unlucky yeah everybody's saying the
sight's crash all right everybody kill
the tense music yeah we're going to be
listening to that for 10 minutes today
on the eve of a great great battle to
determine really the supremacy here on
the H2 podcast I feel like the whole
thing is a little borked I feel like
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
I feel like you you Poison the Well no
I'm sorry no how dare you the other one
lost yeah but you got early on you got
so upset about Trish winning that now
it's the reverse psychology thing are I
can't believe this is coming we have we
have conspiracies coming up Dan that
I I think again like Zach is upset that
it defeated his boy Wally but I mean I
am upset about that that's true but I
think that [__] you Dan is a legitimate
Contender and frankly I think you might
be upset that you're the you're the
subject of ch's ridicule and that might
be fueling your
conspiracy I think Dan's doing the
opposite he's saying some outlandish
stuff so the sound bite hits
harder I think
your well maybe at this point because
I'm talking about it now but [__] you
Dan early on I think uh it got a lot of
I think I think you would be right Dan
if it was Trisha vers Trisha but shout
out to the family prevailed handedly
strongly kept the lead shout out to the
family has continued
command will we ever know the winner
stay in line they never know the winner
stay in your vote counts only if you
stay in line to to vote folks your vote
matters every votee matters fck you
Dan come on straw poo you
[__] shout out to his
[Music]
family Le should giving a shout out to
sto's family here in a minute yep it's
still
down um yeah we should do that love said
we can do in chat voting oh for real
that's prolific why hav we been doing
that the whole time because because only
members can vote on it oh oh oh that's
not good this is too important that's
why I vetoed it earlier this is too
important to do
that stay in line folks we have reports
that the polling stations are being
turned away for the time but uh
just should we do a new link should we
do another one or well does the website
work at all H that's a good question it
doesn't it doesn't appear to be working
at
all all right
okay somebody in the
Discord posted uh I guess it loaded for
them and I don't know if we can trust
these results though but don't say it
because because it could not there could
not have all the dumps it's true I mean
it has 6,000 Vats which is probably not
as many say don't Poison the Well all
right there's a few people posting it
actually apparently it's loading for
people so I think we're I think we got
right back to the tense music
guys it's back everybody get your vote
in your vote
matters more than
ever for Supremacy I'm getting the load
screen maybe not all at
once we come in waves all right we are
coming and we are coming in ways we're
about to see the results of Trisha [__]
you
Dan first shout out to the family I'm
going to edge you my seat you have a hun
result I did it's loading it's just the
website they call him
dumps I think if well you want to talk
about poison well my prediction here is
shout out to the
family but you never know what [__] you
Dan I mean that one has proven to be
such a fierce competive resilient it's
resilient it defeated
Wall-E it defeated let's look at the
bracket back of the bracket while we
wait for the vote to come in look at the
path [__] you Dam took to get
here first of all something is about to
bust defeated
handily that was
brutal before that [__] you Dan
defeating Wall-E that was brutal and
brutal upset that left our sound tech
speechless 91 he's still shaking his
head he he's in
shock Wall-E Co Kenneth
copelan straw pull is down again f
[__] oh no we're so close just let me
finish the
show my throat
hurts so first of all let's are we
getting close to 4 hours yeah something
like that Wally first of all let's watch
the path to Victory defeating Mobility
Mary a strong sound bite but never had a
chance Kenneth Copeland defeated by wall
easily if we look at it seems at David
it seems be loading for a lot of people
cuz I'm con like everybody's posting
screenshots of the results so maybe um
should we ask people to close it if they
already voted would that help I honestly
don't know I mean it's weird that it's
not loading for us at this point let's
follow the uh path here
for shout out to the family now shout
out to the family never really met any
resistance I got to say you know if we
look back Ace family was close really
probably the the strongest competitor of
shout out to the family but but nothing
too strong there I mean one by by four
five points [__] you AB was when I think
it met its biggest resistance the
biggest question mark for me was there
handily W 60 to 40 Easy oh now this was
a test shout out to the family vers
Trump okay mhm no
problem and coming in with the i want to
smell feet defeating I want to smell
feet right out the gate you guys they
call them dumps I mean this is a warrior
of a sound
bite an absolute competitor two true
competitors here up in the finals this
is oh my God it finally [__] loaded
for me just now all right please let me
see the results I want to go
home come on over it I thought we had
some better way to do this other than
straw pull well again this is straw
normally works fine I don't know we just
got unlucky can you turn it on the the
voting can you disable it so it's for
everybody and not just
members uh CH
voting oh the chat isn't there another
website we can use would it help if we
tried a new link or it's no the whole
website's [__] down I mean I have a
different site we could use yeah it went
to 503 eror again let's see if we crash
that one yeah give why why do so many I
mean I kind of know the results like
there's been it seems like most of the
audience isn't having a problem H hold
on
hey wait really you think everyone else
it works for well people keep posting
screenshots of the results with a ton of
votes so somebody's getting through does
straw pull even work I mean straw I
don't know straw
po I linked a different one I mean
doesn't oh wait a new straw or a new
something else different straw.com is
different from straw. me so I made one
over there what the [__] say what Oh's
back wait it's
working okay let hold on hold on before
we post that one let me try to open let
me try to open this one and see if it
works Dan you know I'm on
cam wait what happened
[Laughter]
exact I think SC is
minute we're we're in we're in we got
the
results well and that's a drum roll
moment oh well I already revealed it
so I feel like we got to redo it like
half the audience couldn't
vote I don't think there's over V yeah
more VES than that's that's a that's a
resounding and you frankly I think I
think listen that's a 14 that's a 14 vot
I mean you are talking about I mean
shout out to the family listen it's too
good he he deserved it I think this is
an earned win shout out to his family
and a shout out to his family the first
let's watch to celebrate y can you get
me the d d da do
one The Hamster Dance that's the one
that I really want to play hamster dance
celebrate uh
Dave wow well guys thank you for
participating I mean this was an
exciting this one end nail biting uh
competition a lot of people stuck around
for this I think it's I think it's this
one yeah Dave guda ends
racism and guys guys
guys everybody hail the champion Dave
gach
cheese
2021 H3 podcast world sound bike
champion and thank you to everyone for
celebate for coming and placing your
votes and believing in
democracy and here we go a shout out to
his family this
record thank you thank you in honor of
George
Floyd and I really hope we can see more
unity and more peace Dave when already
so so shout out to his
[Music]
family oh you can't beat that you can't
[__] beat
that
[__] man you guys made the right choice
and you know what I'm happy to see that
the well wasn't poison I think you guys
all made the right choice and just what
can I say shout out to his family I
[__] hell that's just all you could
say well this has been a hell of an
episode guys I have a whole Wendy I have
a whole are you upset I mean Zach are
you upset at least at least I'm happy
with that
one that's a good that's an acceptable
Victor yeah we don't need to overturn we
don't need a revolution
very happy with that canel the rally
yeah okay you're going to storm the
capital or
no
yeah you know we have a whole segment of
Wendy William farts but we'll have to
save this for next week and a lot let me
give you an example no let me just play
one of the ones like this guy Alex
Preston save
ity let me just give you a taste because
he worked on this all week and I feel
bad
I I'm just going to I'll play out I'll
just play us out with this okay so tune
in next week to hear the Wendy Williams
remix fart remix
Willam in next week toot in next
week wait did he send you the real file
why am I watching this video yeah I
don't know
why uh do you guys have the real
file uh
no I sent it to
you all right well all right just played
that it's just exactly it's just a premi
can you crank it
[Music]
Dan
barely
know Dan getas different way I mean what
going
on H there it CS me the [__] out
that's what I'm saying it's h stream
podcast we out here after dark all hours
going for 10 hours you know what it
is shout out to the families of
everybody who's participated here today
tuned in you know we'll be back next
week same time as always baby you know
how it do this is your
boy shout out to the island shout out to
the island man his family I'm going to
have a go have a great Friday I hope you
guys go do have the same right yep thank
you to watching thank you
and we'll see you next week God bless T
byee thanks for
watchingg with me Thena and the whole
damn crew goose and gaps with all the
guest you'll see the best podcast in the
world take it from me JC over chairry XP
baby we podcasting
now yo
to the
three your won next to the
three your won H to the
[Music]
three